day two of the candidates tournament in
Yekaterinburg Russia eight of the top
gladiators in the world were back to do
battle in the race to decide a
challenger for the world championship
title free tournament favorite Fabiano
Caruana dismantled the Russian Carol
Alex anko while the Frenchman Maxime
vasila Grove continued the suffering of
Bing Lauren whose two losses in a row
have him not mired in last place there's
a four-way tie for first with the
players hungry for more wins round three
of exciting action coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
on your screen is the Hyatt Regency in
Yekaterinburg where we see the 20/20
candidates what an exciting tournament
here in Russia I mean it's that battle
to determine the Challenger to Magnus
Carlsen and the entire trust world has
its eyes on it
Grand Master hundred metres here would
grandmaster yes or Sarah one domestic
alejandro hello everyone and welcome to
our coverage of what has been a most
thrilling tournament that's lived up to
its billing and then some Oh games that
are just so full of content let's just
rush right in Alejandro what are the
standings standings as it is four people
died for first place that's half the
tournament Fabiana karana maxi mashallah
graph both wonder games yesterday to
reach that score meanwhile yagna pasha
drew against Alexandra Christian and one
how dropped half a point to fight
honestly by not defeating onigiri from a
winning position to also reach one and a
half 50% for Aleksandra Chris Turk a
little bit of an unusual situation in
which only one person has 50% here is
Alex anko and onigiri both with half a
point and the other big surprise Bingley
Ren what are the pre-tournament
favourites it was a big goose egg there
zero points out of two nobody saw that
coming that's absolutely stunning and
their format the format of the
tournament is a double round-robin
that's 14 rounds for you to ensure that
every player gets an equal amount of
white and blacks if you're a classical
fat this is your tournament hundred
minutes for the first 40 moves fifty
minutes for the next 20 once you reach
move 60 you get another 15 minutes and
then there's a thirty second move per
move throughout no draw offers before
blocks 40th and half a million your
prize fund for the event but let's be
honest only one real winner of the event
the others well they're just going home
with a little bit of cash and a big
disappointment but our schedule the
schedule we have around today and that's
gonna be the third in a row and then a
break day and get used to that schedule
because it's gonna be three games and a
break day three games and a break day
very comfortable schedule earlier
absolutely let's the players rest and
it's a long long event but enough of
this we have breaking news Maurice
actually what is
well it's breaking news indeed
you saw such exciting games so far in
the first two rounds this round has an
incredible game between the two big dogs
off the tournament pre-tournament
favourites ding Lauren and Fabiano
Caruana
and man we are seeing in some of the
best prep we've seen in years
coming from fabulous Fabi in this
position here he played the move e5
they're supposed to be some solid Slav
throw that out the window as he
sacrificed a pawn here to captures here
either one is going to give compensation
for Black Knight takes e5 looks like the
most solid one but Bishop to c2
deflecting the Queen of course if you
capture it and suddenly Queen takes d4
with check is a natural fork winning the
knight on e5 so Queen d2 c5 d 5 Bishop
to b3 now pressuring the pawn after E
for rook e8 hitting the knight who and
therefore and another pawn sacrifice
with the move c4 this one with the
threat of Bishop to d6 that force white
to play Knight takes e4 and calm
development down to pawns
9 f8 repositioning his knight 96 Queen
f5 and now he did some thinking here
before capturing capture in Queen c7
hitting the Bishop Bishop back to e2 not
giving white a chance to breathe every
move it looks like is now with tempo
Bishop takes on c5 and he's been sitting
for a while in this position a crazy one
because the natural capture queen c5
looks all the world like he should do it
but it's a rookie 5 move that looks even
more intriguing an absolutely crazy
crazy game
ding Lauren must be wondering why me why
is the target on my back but in the
meantime his countryman Wang Hao is
playing extremely well and he's the 7
seed from the competition you might
think wow 7 seed not really that famous
but indeed his score against the field
shows that he absolutely belongs against
his countryman ding Lauren
he's five and seven not bad against giri
3 1 griffith 2 1 you see a slight
deficit against both nipple and by
Sheila Grove but what's this
5o against Fabiano Caruana well some of
that was from the younger days but
nevertheless we are talking about
fabulous Fabi this player is indeed very
dangerous as you saw from round one when
he defeated a dig lauren in great style
round two he could say man I should have
gotten that game two against against a
niche giri but no nothing to worry about
he's still at +1 tied for first with a
great chance indeed to keep on and maybe
even win the tournament I think this
would be a shocker if he was the one
that came out of this nobody would have
put money on him but in the meantime we
have a long way to go in exciting games
to start round 3
well thank you Maurice I mean a game
like that as anybody else playing in the
tournament a look at the for round 3
exact or is the game that is gonna get
us thrilled this tingling again swapping
a karana but there are no boring games
today on each curious of fighting
against max Eva Sheila Graham Alexander
Grichuk is currently playing one Hall in
a kind of a weird symmetrical French bat
trough he really likes Cinco meanwhile
is in a complicated also French against
Yamaha Miyaichi and look at that unusual
scenario every single leader with the
black pieces
some of them fighting for the win forget
it with this prep like psycho being the
lower rated player so you aren't playing
something that's not very usual of his
repertoire with a nitrous player it's
nepalese said I don't want to run into
cureless brat let's play a French and
fight it out exactly well I mean again
you're right there are four exciting
games but let's just drill down a little
bit further into this we got number one
versus number two match up and whenever
the number one is a number two matches I
don't care what sport it is I mean
that's where the attention plays and
sometimes unfortunately in the world of
chess when number one plays number two
it's a boring affair yeah not today
Alejandro I mean just from the get-go
this move e5 I mean
what can you say about the Slav I mean
it's one of the oldest most established
defenses in the world and nobody I meet
in generations of players have come up
with this novel move e6e 5-z fantastic
fantastic c5 is a normal continuation in
this position right the theory that's
the theory and it's been played there's
a bunch of 2700 games here right
supposed to be a little bit better for
white okay nothing special right and
probably what they leave unexpected of
course five comes like a thunder now put
yourself in dinger inches you're - -
you're in the tournaments gone off you
know like as bad as it could possibly
get and suddenly you're getting hit
again with this movie five and you got
to be saying here so somebody give me a
break here we're a little harsh when we
say this but it's not so far from the
truth there will be one winner and seven
losers exactly and then the red doesn't
want to be a loser he wants to win of
course when he needs to start scoring
wins yeah and this was this is a great
chance for him he's white he's white
he's against Fabi which means that he
will shorten that distance against one
of the players
he needs to it exactly pull them back
right at this point look at the position
right and you think Knight takes e5 okay
well obviously my opponents very well
prepared Bishop c2 comes on the board
and at this point I think somebody in a
different term and situation maybe
somebody more cautious just takes the
bishop and just says hey no prep I'm
gonna go home I'm gonna go home let's
just make some kind of draw give you
your palm back right solidify my king
but no the tournament situation demands
that I have to play on
absolutely and Engler and us Queen to c5
okay now I don't want to take that no so
it looks kind of forced forced and then
this bishop drops back it hits the pawn
on d5 you've got to defend that guy now
suddenly you hit me with rook e8 now I
start to worry about things like rook
takes e4 absolutely Knight moves so I
get Queen f4 does look force to me right
and c4 Wow instantly by Bobby obviously
still in the sprat I was 56 is a huge
it forces again daily rounds have
nothing to be done Knight takes e4
Knight bt7 like what's that but nice
quiet move you just sacrifice to pawn
modern chess monetize this is great
understanding I think the engines of old
had a lot of problems understanding this
kind of sacrifices they saw two pawns
central pawns no check means no
checkmate y-yeah just better for what
yeah and even modern chess and gears
when they're not very strong you're
using your online engine or you're using
your laptop that's running Windows boot
cap you know it's probably giving whites
winning right but we have very strong
engines now the Leela even the new stop
dishes they drill much deeper okay they
understand that compensation here might
not be in the next move in the next
couple moves they understand it's gonna
be a while before white develops right
and he has he plays Bishop III kind of
protecting protecting his King on the
dark squares there was a vulnerabilities
of Bishop c5 check so Bishop e3 another
move is this move is a tickle because
the White Queen on f4 yeah some little
bit boxed in so Bishop d4 making room
for the Queen I know maybe this was
asking too much queen fi because you can
see the White Queen getting a little bit
and into trouble here maybe it was time
to withdraw Queen d2 Queen d2 might walk
in a rookie for I take a back Queen C
one Queen c1 was the weak engine
recommendation I I don't know what Bobby
had played prepared against us okay but
certainly there was some plan office by
this point fire has blitzed out every
move exactly so and by the way while fab
is blitzing out every move what's
happening to ding Lorenz clock you can
see it down to 15 minutes Dingley right
at a weak engine recommendation if I
were ding Lorraine
if I haven't seen this position I don't
want my Queen on that five I mean I
think I just don't like I'm not sitting
there going you know what let me stick
my queen in the guys we engine whatever
I'm not putting my queen in at five it
just seems like maybe I should go home
right
we stole stuff let's go back and
consolidate maybe white maybe I have to
ditch back a couple of pawns I'm already
thinking I'm giving you back a couple of
pawns if I have to make a draw now
because you're still blitzing out moves
but the idea of leaving the Queen
sitting right there to get a hit again
that just seems scary and okay the way
the game transpired it worked out Oh
more or less worked out I'm still not
happy with the position for white
because it's hard to develop the pieces
especially that rook on h1 but man what
else would you I mean you were you happy
with a queen of five well let's find out
who's going to be happy to play should
be two then Bishop c5 very very logical
move you eliminate that powerful pitcher
from d4 and expose the King on f2 as
well I can't imagine a better move than
Bishop c5 agreed so he takes on c5 e
starts thinking here and this is kind of
a key point okay because we do have more
moves over but rookie five was the main
alternative he did end up taking the
bishop with check but rookie five was
certainly a very tempting alternative
kicking out this mean also gaining a lot
of Tempe here for example Knight f4 also
is a temple so very tempting
continuation that Bishop is always
hanging yeah I you know it's at these
moments I start thinking in terms of
bailing out right like like where
where's the past why do you mean exactly
exactly and I start thinking like okay I
I may end up having to give up my queen
somewhere somehow but by the way I just
want to point out one point is that the
desirable for example one parachute move
that I'd like to bail out with you know
yeah yeah I got I've got a rook a bishop
a couple of pawns but unfortunately
Queen takes e5 is with a check I lose I
lose the house so okay so so rookie five
I agree a very tempting move e5 let's
take a look at a little bit because okay
she cuz we're gonna be able to look at
the actual game continuation but this is
line with g5 whoa g5 okay I got no
choice and now Queen c5 check okay
no choice and now the move Knight F an
ID on f6 takes on d5 rut ro holy smokes
and after pawn takes why are you giving
away a piece right of Queen III just
posting up against the bishop and men
and pieces are not the way to Queens on
86th or us on h1 and rook on a1 and it's
all about the black pieces despite being
down gobs of material actually how much
material it's a couple of pawns in a
piece it's one pawn and a piece one part
like pasted killed I doubled you could
treble on the e line your Kings going
nowhere you're never developing anybody
what a line Bobby would have had to seen
all this to go forward this is an insane
line this one this is alien chest this
is amazing stuff he didn't do that
by the way he got c5 with Chuck he did
make them obvious recapture and by the
way obvious and strong I mean what
happened after that
Wow though clear why he didn't just say
I think he spent some some deep o'clock
time before finally saying you know what
I want to play that move but it looks
risky let me go for this okay h6 what
that is a shocker
h7 h6 saying your two pawns up that you
don't have a good continuation that's
amazing that is amazing because there's
a natural move attacking rook e5 Queen
before moves that seemed to pressure the
position in some way eight six it's
making looked for the king because I
might get made it on the background
it also taken away g5 I was kidding yeah
it's like a weird tempo loss why do you
need to take away g5 when rookie five
would have easily covered that square
I'm not entirely sure what the point of
a success don't look at me
I've been stunned from the get-go here
eight
seven age six oh they definitely hate
the movers Wow because it just seems
like slow so slow given the situation
but you know here's what I will say
though is a plus for this move okay good
the plus for the move is if you don't
have a reorganization plan as white
exactly what is your next move and which
is very logical it before I mean that's
know by the way yeah that's know the
clock times this is really stress the
stress level that ding Lauren must be
feeling all right now
15 minutes left on the clock to make 18
more moves in this position where you
can't develop your pieces your rookie
stood in the corner the guys sacrificed
a couple of pawns on you and your Queen
might get trapped in some weird line and
you don't want to play this you just
don't want to play it so you need easy
moves think about this for a second in
this sharp position 15 minutes okay he's
got 15 minutes we know as players right
how fast the clock goes right the clock
you you're sitting there thinking and
eight minutes went by what just happened
and you start making quick moves I would
not be surprised if this game is decided
by a blunder by white I wouldn't be
surprised in the slightest because all
Fabi needs to do now is play a couple of
strange-looking moves things that you
have to think about little thread here
little thread there find the right way
to pressure the position and ding Lauren
could go into a long tank long tank when
you only have 15 minutes left is five
minutes and look at the lifetime score
to to of course we'd expect this from to
2800 players but but with the momentum
is something leerin it was to 0 for Fabi
oh and then ding they're in tied at
two-two especially with a key victory in
Norway to me and last year right
Armageddon slash normal tournament yes
yes they were destroyed Fabi in the
normal time control Wow yeah and I want
to say it was in some kind of love or a
capital N type slot position well again
2019 wasn't a fantastic year for ding
and that's where it started
and that's always and that's where ding
therein is perceived today as a favorite
into this candidates tournament is
absolutely bonkers one rookie one
Maurice was saying something about
creating threads creating weird moves
and I'm trying to come up with a plan
for black because okay I'm down to pasta
night or something I have been yelled at
in my ear of something ridiculous which
was a 65 very ridiculous idea computer
suggestion also of our version of Cobian
in the truck is looking at it it's in be
fine you want to open up the position
that seems so slow here's the thing it's
exam so it seems like you shouldn't be
making par moves but here's the thing
how are you going to actually break
White's position right the only way is
there are only two ways normally in
chess there are two main ways right well
let's let's start with the the first
thing you do one is you attack things
until the person can defend them okay
right
you just keep attacking pressure
pressure pressure person is holding
holding holding holding holding you hold
on tight so now I can't break through
well what do I do I have to sacrifice so
or well I don't have to sacrifice the
next step is pawn breaks you need a palm
break something you push something and
you crack the position open because the
pawn structure is in your way so you
need a pawn break a6 b5 is that kind of
break the only one well f5 is also in
the position my apologies f5 in some
future line is also there as a movement
we've seen it in previous variations the
other way is sacrifice a piece on those
dumb pawns
so something we've seen the night takes
the five idea something like 94
something to crack the position so
actually a 6 b5 is just within one of
those themes what do you do you play to
open up the position some more now it
looks very slow the issue becomes does
white have two or three moves that fixes
his position in the meantime and that's
the main question can you guys come up
with an answer to a six does he have a
g3 King g2 roof H e1 hey I'm well
organized while you're busy doing that
movie there's a rookie buddy there is no
Ruki fellow why because it doesn't
belong with the position I don't know
trying it out in my ear that is if I was
the idea
there's no rookie 5 as part of that fun
okay I was trying to get a night off and
the other sacrifice of course is night
take C 3 so you could play something
along the lines of Queen B for Rookie
two rooks e8 but I'm sitting there
saying you know that's why the move h7
h6 is so darn confounding oh yes you
know you said there you want to be
cracking that whip with you know great
attacking moves and let's face it this
is phenomenal preparation so I've got to
figure that eight-six it Queen b6 I've
been told it's all part of Abby's
preparation by the way after you play
the move Queen b6
there's no a6 b5 let's get back with the
Trojans
Maxon that's really important in this
position yeah really important when you
sacrifice material for compensation play
like you sacrifice material for
compensation right don't play like you
lost the material right oh man I'm down
to pawns I need to get it back how do I
get it back Queen b6 the intent of Queen
b6 is not simply to get back to pawn on
b2 the point is to try to erode White's
position that one pawn is holding the
night together and if that goes in a
four point is hanging something you got
to pass pawns
he's not just I got to get the material
back so it's an you have to recognize it
from an attitude standpoint a6 is even
more so playing like you sacked like all
right I sacrifice no big deal I'm not
gonna have that attitude so it's very
important that you realize when you
sacrifice you sacrifice you didn't
blunder the two pawns and you need to
get it back you sacrifice those pawns so
that's why we might be a little worried
about a move like Queen b6 the other
thing I don't like about Queen b6 is
it's so concrete that my opponent knows
exactly what to do on the next move he's
already you've gotta depend upon the
part rugby to no thought for ding
Lorraine you make an attacking move I
defend so a6 had that that very unclear
motive about it well b5 may come or not
because the square is guarded more than
twice but actually we do have Queen e3 I
mean
you guys are mentioning a sex before
it's not an idea but Queen III roof c2
a6 looks so much stronger because now
the wheel is posted up on there's room
in the first okay so as I played b5 you
can't really take on b5 right so i-i
mean you you're you're talking about
Maurice you know disguising your
attacking yaks and not being so a you
know straightforward a on the board but
I don't know Queen b6 Queen III use
maybe is force I mean a good I don't
have an engine but that looks pretty
compelling to me I mean it looks really
strong those are also the threats that
we want to see exactly play right
intuition says well actually be making
threats
exactly and even now you mentioned a6
right
rook c2 let's be clear you mentioned a6
b5 alright Andrew all this is tied the
way ding Laurens got very little time so
he's making the mosey has to play yeah
so it couldn't but we let's not let's
not analyze retrospective or retro
actively right okay we're we're saying
oh yeah now a6 b5 looks really strong we
didn't see a six in the first place no
no okay we can't pretend that we saw
this move in advance we see Queen b6 we
see Queen to e3 we might be looking for
another piece move right now what other
threats do we have it's only because the
a6 movers do pointed out to us that we
realize hey that plan is in the position
that looks pretty darn good and and so
this maneuver with Queenie Queen b6
Queen e3 strengthens the idea of a 6 b5
so that kind of bias is typical in the
thinking of you know all humans have
but will he find a six we know a six is
on the board
the weird idea will he find a six and is
that why he played Queen c5 - III
because when I look at the Queen five
yeah it wants to come back it wants to
go to f2 was the Queen reaches after I
think black resigns right queen h3 Queen
g3 Queen F to write any a queen trade to
pounds up resides right so anything that
gets the Queen back I kind of dislike
for black
okay it was a rookie five Queen age
three queen g3 queen f2 just seems very
bad to me for example rookie five queen
h3 rook g5 trying to cut that idea yeah
I was trying to I was playing around
with the in view of g3 I thought okay
let's try a chief I but again you're
helping me right g3 yeah
that wing g2 queen of - I'm killing my
own pieces I feel well in one way you
are you definitely the knight on g6 is
crying but I was thinking am i weakening
f3 and yes I have but can I attack it
maybe not so okay we're trying to find
an alternative please Maurice effect
you're gonna switch on us now there are
other games going on there are other
games as well in a very exciting moment
in this one one of the leaders in the
event Yana problem the chief playing
against the bottom seeded player in the
tournament Kira likes Enco but how do we
know the bottom seeds can be dangerous
Knight back to e7 after Bishop d3 Bishop
d2 guarding is pawn and I see six inning
the rook saying move it out of there no
I refuse you can have my room take it
please
Knight takes on b4 eight eggs before
straightening out the pawn structure
this Bishop my name for not looking that
great at the moment Queen c7 and now
rook to e1 and we have this kill kill
beasts a very interesting position as
well if we weren't so transfixed by the
big dawgs
numbers 2 & 3 in the world playing we'd
be thinking well what's this about an
interesting exchange sacrifice at night
will end up on d4 this Bishop doesn't
look that great f4 f5 with ideas who do
you like in this position that was an
inspired exchange sacrifice I love white
I totally I thought it was reasonable
for Bach until I realized there up
actually a panic so the bottom seat huh
yeah he just played Knight be a very
wise move nettles part because he sees
what's coming Knight d4 and f4 coming so
he's looking to try to get rid of this
night
on the square right but man if white
gets the pawns rolling it's gonna be big
trouble
86 for favi hey 656 for Fabia goodness
so he's going for it he's going for a 6
b5 nepo he's doing the nipple thing he's
playing a chaotic game up on time
tremendously how many times have I seen
nipple in a lost position not saying
that he's lost right now not at all yeah
just blitz off some stuff and then his
opponent makes one mistake in there in
trouble and that's all he needed exactly
we saw that in Zagreb you were there in
Croatia when that was happening yes and
the time trouble and I just is such a
big point I move like a six it's not
like necessarily a veiled threat that
he's gonna play the move b5 and not
exactly veiled but what's also critical
is there no easy moves here your queen
you feel uncomfortable I quit on f5
remember we said we wish that pops the
way we engine move it'd be so nice to be
back home right now what are you doing
way ahead of the army the king is
separating this rook on h1 my late my
late friend Ronald Simpson one of the
guys who was most instrumental in me
becoming a strong chess player he is
just used to say to me it was the first
time he really explained and I
understood if your works not in the game
it doesn't even exist on the board like
it's not playing there's what that's not
a rook you call that a road okay look at
this thing this thing is out of the game
so if we go like this and say this is
out of the game if we took this rook or
if you say well of course black is
winning black is completely ahead he's
ahead of rook and indeed black is ahead
of rook in the temporal sense if Black
gets going and the action starts Minh
stuff hits the fan white is going to be
down the road at the moment a queen
misplaced you could just end up being
much better for block now the engines
are saying we can defend we can defend
we can defend but a human sitting
looking at this board with no time on
the clock easy to see a blunder that
makes him go way down yeah oh it's so
difficult
oh absolutely how many times we've been
in winning positions that are unclear
they're winning but unclear now your
time sticking and you enter panic panic
mode you see the threats and you see
that there's five different ways for you
play none of them loose but none of them
really deal with the threats right and
it's just chaotic
yeah and confidence is difficult at that
point yeah and you just said it it's a
very very key concept in chess your
confidence yeah ding glare in after
these two losses is this Wow
the winds completely out of his sails
right I mean he's like oh this is so bad
but now with the time ticking down sorry
I was just looking at no no it was just
it all came out of almost a forest
opening prep onigiri is a green fell
player he's playing against one of the
world's most committed green fell
players MBL it's always interesting to
see when you get to yeah heavyweight
players who play the same opening what
they're going to do I think uh Nisha's a
little bit better
I like the rook and Bishop versus pretty
bad for block if you can get your King
on f2 to eat King f2 to come up the
board to e4 version is telling me way up
back in the opening that actually MBL
came up with a novel idea 97 this is a
new approach for this specific thing
lying and things happen really really
quickly not the most right right but an
ending that favors our niche by the way
and each needs to get back in into the
game Maurice over to you a very
interesting moment occurred in this
position with a lysenko and nip oh he
nice night meant to be a night of course
went to d4 a knight c6 understanding you
have to get rid of this Knight now this
piece we talked about that piece doesn't
count what pieces don't count because
they're sitting there this piece is not
gonna count for a while unless you can
somehow break through on this file and
be able to play Bishop takes c2 the
bishop on other is just like big pawn
right so he's worried about how he's
gonna get something go maybe he can play
to move a 5 as well and get something
here to make the structure pass so that
he can play Bishop takes c2 otherwise is
in big trouble
the answer is give Knight takes c6 Queen
takes and queen g4 right natural
pressure g7
if you play g6 and queen back there's a
queen lining on f6 your pawn structure
is about to get just cracked with h5 as
well very nice position
instead he played queen g4 first sorry
96 he played queen g4 immediately
allowing night ace
now he didn't want to lose his
initiative his threat on the g7 square
with Queen takes d4 which the Indian
gives his best he now played pawn takes
and now this move releases the exact
point we're talking about some future
plan and the distance that black will
wish he gets now the bishop says okay I
see a way into the game I'm working so
now it's working that's the key it's
working we talked about the rook in the
other position in the Diggler
Inquisition
it wasn't working on h1 now this Bishop
says oh yeah so what are you doing I'm
attacking the pawn oc2 I can't take it
just yet but I will one day so this
sequence might have been not the right
way just exact right where we talked
about the difference between live twenty
seven hundred and twenty-eight hundreds
and consistently playing those good
moves and not allowing the guy in the
game and it looks like he realized let
neppo back in the game depo can even
play wild with g5 in this position
apparently a very sharp move but now
he's got a whole different attitude
about it now I'm up an exchange yeah I'm
up an exchange I want to open some files
c2 or hang later and you don't have the
same initiative you would have had
before
Thank You Maurice for that and one final
update going on in the game between
Alexander Grisha plain how this has been
a very slow game but the two bishops for
Alexander Grisha Creek starting with two
draws in the competition playing one of
the tournament leaders you know we were
part is just one win by chrish hook and
he's tied for first and he's right back
in the tournament as well it seems a bit
more blessing for bishop pair of bishops
there's an isolated 495 exactly wrist
thing because white is behind in
development considerably yeah the first
ring right I'm probably going to play
rook b1 it should be two maybe yellow
yeah maybe on a good day challenge one
of the files probably the C file that
sounds great let's go too far exactly
and now that we've made our rounds and
touch base on all the bases again I'd
quickly put the Queen back h3 g3 which
makes a lot of sense that's what we're
talking about if this for with white
sight put the cleaner on f2 we thought
was the queen reaches f2 that's it
you're right so a6 b5 fabbi continues
this idea now you're on the defense one
of the things that you absolutely can't
do is open up the position any moves
like a four takes b5 would be a no-no
will flap your hands and say you don't
open up the position against your king a
Bab you're doing black a great favor a
great service thank you very much rook a
1 will stream into the back rank so
Queen g3 obvious move before was played
again I'll be smooth this knight on c3
it's kind of holding everything together
yeah exactly so let's give it the boot
it doesn't feel like there's only one
move 91 by the way it's the Queen yeah
and Queen Queen trap but I'm looking
sorry
pawns to get the file I'm gonna do
everything I want to do as much as I can
with tempo I like will be three because
the Queen is really annoying it's still
attacking a lot of things and it's a
temple there's a currency to it's very
uncomfortable it wants to stay on c2
because it covers both the second-ranked
and it covers the C file so you're kind
of making it shoes do you want to go to
c6 you want to go to d2 there's
advantage and sudden disadvantages for
both right I would say Ruby - looks like
the more logical move yeah
I'm wondering if I continue the pressure
with something like rook c8 rook c1 or
do I start taking up on can I take upon
an Queen the a pawn and I'm a pawn
grabber but I gotta tell you I would go
for the attacking moves rook c8 rook c1
it just feels like yeah I wanna stream
into White's position but c4 doesn't
work because I think your queen on b3 is
hanging no it's not oh it's not hanging
is it that sweet Knight takes e4 give me
the rook take I know that's the crazy is
a crazy line and I
sure Y can do better than what I'm doing
but although even they hear you only
want to pawn right so you're still worse
didn't want to the only one one rook
takes you for but because I am even in
Ponce there's a second where did I win
the second part oh okay sorry takes e4
is sadly by to d3
that was a muscle if I apologize rook d3
oh that's a nice move and I'm sorry to
say yes you know one of those things
about attacking moves we are only we
think there are only pluses to those
moves it's only positives
we're being aggressive right attacking
we're attacking or attack we're tiny but
there's always negatives to things even
if you don't notice it we talk about
drawback chess one of the drawbacks of
all these moves that why is playing yeah
it's actually organizing the most blacks
playing is organizing White's defenses
white is slowly tightening the pieces
knitting them together then I don't do
one looks bad for now and it is not in a
great space but if you look at that
position with the rook guarding the
night guarding the bishop with the King
the Queen now remember we had a queen on
f5 now it's going back now to join the
party on f2 and d4 now you started to
say way you can win one back you could
win two back but if I play Queen d4 and
then I get my kings f2 and then the
other work comes in my Knights gonna
jump to e3 you're not Queenie so easily
and don't forget the deep on that d5
pawn exists then those central pawns
they do exist you get a little f4 action
with an e5 thing you won't be talking
about white as being so bad anymore so
Bobby has to be mindful here that he is
knitting together
White's harmony in this position that
white didn't have before and why it's
just two moves away from castling you
hear me say castling that's a king f2
castling by hand rookies
the game and then that's it so let's be
mindful the guy is up to pawns it's not
like you can just sit back and say he's
never gonna make any moves and never
gonna make any progress because you know
I've been attacking all this time right
this is a very tricky situation right
now for for me no I agree the diode d1
is such a solid piece it holds
everything together to pawn to e3 square
kicking out that Queen from e3 was such
a nice tempo of idea I like the idea of
taking on a former in the Queen and
queen in the pawn but it is pretty slow
so it does come down to the 10 feet and
you're showing some variations I saw you
right I was just trying to figure out if
I just played some natural moves for
both players and what what Maurice is
saying that 93 King f2 white starts to
harmonize there is a deep on and you're
not queening so easily back to the I
believe this is the current position
guys ah we've been talking about rook c8
rook c1 is an alternative when we're
talking about Queen takes a four but
also what does what does rotate actually
do develop a piece yeah bringing my rook
into the game as Maurice has been
talking about his mentor a teacher who
said if your rooks not participating
it ain't rug so rook c8 rook c1 is
participating guard d1 it's not saying
that I'm doing anything super special I
just if the pawn was on h5 what are you
doing and by the way this is great prep
great prep we've been saying that ever
since we got here but has black yeah you
mean or just stopped slow yeah
did he play too slowly with the move a
six and did this idea of Queen c5 Queen
III six - III yeah did this no this just
simply allow white to what looks like
not harmonized because you bring a knife
back but actually as you look at it
looks like solidified even more and
white brands to play Queen f2y plans to
play
Monsieur pushing looks like you're
pushing I'm pushing I'm pushing yeah
you're pushing him to good squares
Thanks yeah now he wants to play Queen
f2 he wants to play g3 and make your
knight on e4 on g6 not have any future
and play King g2 that's another point as
well Queen the d4 I mean it's just white
starting to look too solid why is
looking sensible this move is not any
threat with rook rook to c1 rook c8 work
c1 what's your next idea this he's
taking on a four by the way right now
he's gotten one pawn back whitey that's
not white is thrilled for one you did
all that and think about it all that
hard work what progress did black bake
getting this pawn back what has moved
take a look answer the question we go
all the way back to Queen b6 okay you
know Queen b6 we're gonna go here right
here
you play Queen b6 yeah in this position
so you know get the Knights look at the
rooks look at blacks position yep in
Queen b6 alright now we go fast forward
to the current position and whites queen
is backed up
White's Queen has shifted to g3 why to
solidify with a knight on d1 even player
and and the rook on d2 and you take a
pawn and now it's White's move again to
do something useful in other words all
those moves you gained a queen on a four
you got one pawn and a pawn on b4 which
is not saying much right now it's not
very convinced made a lot of moves you
made a lot of moves to get one pawn back
when you were attacking and punching and
hitting you made a lot of booze in the
meantime why does plate a lot of useful
moves to get to this case like we have
to almost immediately Queen on f5 which
was misplace is suddenly coming to this
beautiful finally on d4 which again will
will help White's King g2 g3 King g2
we D for king of two well suddenly
harmony and whites position lorries what
is the engine evaluation that white is
completely winning like way ahead almost
three pawns yeah way of guys I'm Way
ahead I was really really excited by
what Barbie was doing but now I feel
like age six was slow the Queen maneuver
wasn't accurate he probably played a
little bit on his opponents clock
putting myself in in Abbey shoes and
rooster my coaches showing me this
position I'm getting more thrilled and
thrilled and thrilled until I see the
move age six that was the move that was
the damper right there you had mentioned
Queen before you'd mentioned rookie five
even a six in this position somehow that
rook on a one became a useful move on a
useful rook on d2 it's just so difficult
to understand him of aged six cuz okay
Queen g5 I understand trying to move the
Queen back to d2 but getting back into
the game visa view this way but we were
looking at Queen before we were looking
at rook c5 and also a6 and very strange
evaluation is fabi's just lost lost by a
lot yeah nothing to do about the playing
g3 and King g2 nothing you have nothing
you have no progress you're not you
haven't done anything and you're not
doing anything it's just a loss position
for black right now objectively speaking
look on you're a pawn down great center
in fact in fact I'll say this if you
dropped us on this board like we walked
you didn't see before we say laws this
is this seems weird the king on f1
what's the pawn count well there's six
against five black has it's like what
might have something what is a for most
will visit oh wait what is it's gonna
White's gonna play g3 hey wait a minute
what if white plays g3 King g2 and
brings of records at the end what does
black half that's what we'd be saying
exactly what you just dropped us in
we're just we have the illusion of
having seen all the crazy moves would
predict at this point yeah but now that
we look we go
no I don't mm-hmm we're not happy I'm
not happy at all there has to be some
craziness with rook takes you for being
an actual threat impressed otherwise
blacks position is just being owned
exactly you start to say if I don't have
ideas of rook takes e4 or Knight takes
e4 and exploit immediately the
unpleasant position of whites King right
I got nothing put upon the way this see
if digging the rent one this just blows
the tournament you'll be back at the
other fingering I mean true but the
other guys the other guys any other
result that was not a dangler and
victory reasoning therein mathematically
get out of here right already have two
whites your tournaments over dirt yeah
but he wins he waited you're minus one
you can try to find control right and
then dealer ends back in determined
that's one more incredibly important
person right who suddenly gets when
behind the sales wow that's what I'm
talking about
we started the show by saying you know
like what an amazing event it's been so
far this round three is just kind of
breaking news yes we do indeed have
breaking news as we have the first
result of the round we're not so
surprised by it but Maxine Vashti magrav
and unease Giri have contracted peace
today we're gonna go home Versailles
Treaty no not quite but let's just take
the draw and get the heck out of here
this game has ended in a draw so
currently mice in vascular Grove is in
clear first but we expect that to change
shortly but certainly that result an
important one for the event exactly and
it was a repetition because there was no
draw offer right MERS right you're not
allowed to accept the draw before move
for tea or offered or offer a draw
before
40 so this happened I see for Brooke to
d3 and he just kept bothering this piece
and he kept going back and they were now
I appreciate that
Anisha isn't having a great tournament
but why didn't
Anish repeat the position why didn't a
niche for example avoid the repetition
with the move rook c2 after Knight c4 in
293 probably yeah I was thinking that he
would play Brooks I guess yeah rook c2
Knight e3 AHA and if I try to go maybe
you see one sure that white is better
anymore ninety five ninety three ninety
five ninety three uh-huh I was hoping
that White's King could play a more
useful role than it currently is ninety
five and ninety three I mean that is a
tempo yeah yeah fair enough
okay a fair result there by those two
players and how is nepo doing by the way
because when we left it he had climbed
his way back in the game thanks to this
Knight takes d4 and this Bishop is alive
whoa
we left it here we were thinking that g7
g5 was a possibility Bishop takes you to
immediately just simply runs into rook
c1 and that's a that would be a
tremendous that's gonna be either the
tactic for a while it's actually it will
not be hanging for a very long time
right
also note that white doesn't want to
simply consolidate with c3 because that
also would release the bishop for action
ok g 6h fight whoa
no I think you have to do this because
your rooks need breathing room otherwise
you don't have any actual files true
good point
and he has castle position I think yes
Alex anko seven minutes for the next
12th moves not that great actually
because he has a tough choice now either
do nothing and wait which is also a
tough thing to do we want to play a five
somewhere but that's the thing you start
releasing blacks rooks exactly but I
feel that long term being an exchange
if I don't you know force the action
with that five rook f1 rook f6 or
something some does I'm just gonna lose
the game though let's take a look fi
looks incredibly logical to me right of
course the engines hate it of course
because you're opening up the physician
for the rooks and maybe rook g8 not too
sure Oh Bishop takes e2 works they
should take C to work yeah it works now
Oh cuz of the beep on rook c1 Queen b6
yes you're getting out of the pin and
take on d4 with a check I've played f4 5
yeah thank you exposing my King right
now then it's exactly then you have to
actually cover so I'm actually obliged
to play c3 Bishop I don't believe it of
course I think that this is a solid
exchange response before still not
amazing no but it's useful unlike on a4
right whatever yeah I I really like the
exchange sacrifice I just didn't like to
follow up I agree that the compensation
here is they're still still there yeah
but it's not clear it does feel like the
rook is getting that power you see the
position opening up the bishops me
becoming better and better
that's right obviously there's no
threats on blacks King right so my neck
was gonna slowly bring the rooks it
might be very difficult to actually
convert in my difficult to make progress
but now it does feel like it's a black
advantage exactly it that's exactly
right
a quick glance before we start to take
our first break of the day this is the
game of guruship versus wang hao again
wang hao is one of those players one of
our leaders who could have potentially
been - oh he had a winning position
yesterday he did let Anish escape Bishop
d2 immediately inviting black to capture
on v2 was Chris Chuck's idea Bishop
takes b2 by the way rook b1 thank you
white would just thank his opponent for
letting the
Brook into the game so we're not gonna
see a bishop takes B - what are we gonna
see instead here I would probably just
defended b7 pawn something like either
rooky 7 or c7 I'm not sure there's
something of sense to me the difference
that I saw is white was somehow trying
to how do you say I steal a tempo
because the moment before I was playing
rook e1 Bishop d2 now I'm inviting you
to take and I would recapture with the
bishop and I kind of feel like hey you
know progress is being made here so
small for why I you know I do that and
again during the game when I sit there
and I packed myself on the back I said
oh I saved myself a temple insightful
move Bishop d2 okay if I had to bet it's
very draw game yeah but on the other
hand you're at the board yeah I'd rather
be white right that was what Kenneth
says Anka said to me once when I said
yeah the positions the positions equal
in Genesis yeah but gentlemen before
we're ready for our first night not not
quite yet but we're gonna be taking a
break soon yes do we have any other
moves I think that Bobby's tanking and
that's something we really should talk
about because favi he's played a lot of
quick moves he got into the attack and
dig around it seems like he's had 10
minutes for the last hour right right
you're right because it's always been
Bobby thinking Bobby's the one that
proposed the position game of the pawns
I put the threats but now he's running
out of steam right and as a player you
kind of realize something's going wrong
the guy's not down as much material my
position is not great where do I create
the character where do I practically put
that pressure on my opponent to keep
myself in the game
perhaps Maurice can tell us a little bit
more about what's happened in the
tourney but first of all you've got some
highlights for us though Maurice of the
two rounds well it indeed has been a
special event so we want to just recap
the top five highlights from the first
two rounds some beautiful moves that you
will see and we're gonna start with
number five between boxing by Sheila
Grove and Fabiano Caruana
sacrifice has happened on f7 Knight
takes on f7 it looks like there's gonna
be some dangerous discovery in this
position but Fabi kept his cool and
played the surprising efore saying do
what you want with me tonight anywhere I
don't care turns out that there is no
great discovery in this position
efore is a wonderful move he went on of
course with many adventures to draw this
game number four from round two well
this one was a beat down by Sheila
Graham of an already secured a fantastic
position against Engler in finish it off
in style with the move b7 e7 nice move
if you capture the knight 94 check is a
crushing fork he kept with the bishop
and allowed Bishop to a5 and that simply
wins a piece and the game that was it
ding Lauren had to resign after Bishop
to a5 b7 a great move and now to number
three from round one again [ __ ] ding
Lauren this time against his countryman
to Wang Hao and in this position plank
played the beautiful rook to g4
sacrificing in exchange take it if you
want to but those pawns corrected
themselves are connected themselves and
just became too powerful and resignation
was soon after this fantastic move and
now to number 2 we saw it from fabulous
Fabi against the bottom seen Alex Sink
oh he had an attack did Fabi an extra
piece putting the pressure but he
dropped the bomb with the move Knight
takes on h5 opening up that King he
followed it up very strongly with a
Bishop to f5 that was all she wrote in
this game
this was all he could do but resigned
schwa he actually tried to play the like
Cinco and was finished off an
embarrassing style but a crushing blow
by Caruana but number one is so nice
we've got tools to show first of all in
this position with Geary versus napalm
the Chi the move b5 what a shocker that
one must have floored Geary when he saw
it the sacrifice not seemingly usual but
the point is to create that past seep on
a square an escort down the board with
c2 he was not able to capture this pawn
after b5 he captured on c3 later I have
to give up his queen and then he tried
to create a fortress in this position
but it was no real fortress because of
our move up the first two rounds Queen
d3 a very special move indeed
sacrificing the Queen you cannot capture
it because the pawn will capture and
Queen itself and now the king is ready
to march the c3 to d2 and create all
kinds of havoc this position this move
caused resignation by Geary so we've
seen some very special moves so far
there are highlights from the first two
rounds boy thank you for those those are
really wonderful memories I remember
that efore by Fatih because I was
frightened as I go my goodness
and the yells got this crushing attack
and just eat for just like he refused to
see ghosts no intimidation whatsoever
comfortable game even he wouldn't maybe
even was a major part of the game but ok
that one physical into a little bit of a
draw speaking of fire let's go to his
game there a couple more moves ok
retreat Queen d7 okay after he captured
the pawn on a4 William did see the move
Queen f2 as expected the Queen is
bringing it herself back into the fight
with Queen d4 maybe g3 maybe for King F
273 was played okay we're from Abby's
boarding view he's trying to get a
passed pawn and Queen that pawn with a 5
a 4 g2 g3 by the way just echoing the
thoughts of Maryse that once you play
the move g3 the night on GC
starts to cry a little bit hey how am I
gonna get in the game Queen age three
check Wow
I'm very quickly king g1 that's a reply
I'm gonna do which I am very surprised
because I guess queen g2 what was the
plan when g2 I think I'm going back but
then I can play Queen f2 and if I have
ten minutes on the clock and I think
about that from a practical standpoint
in Queen g2 was the better move from a
practical standpoint the only question
was if the Queen's better on c8 and
after Queen if two black hats another
move but I'm not so sure about a lot
easier black is in deep trouble in this
position guys black wants to repeat and
pray for the draw Oh
lighting is trying to develop King g1 by
ding Lauren is a move that says you got
your great prep you got all those nice
moves and I'm gonna crush you now now
I'm gonna make you pay you made me
suffer you didn't play sprightly enough
chess and now I'm gonna make you pay and
I was I mean he looks like he's burying
his rook on the square that's not gonna
last he's gonna move his Queen then he
still playing Knight f2 and boot the
black Queen out of the position guard
everything so Queen d4 9f2 King g2 rook
to rook on h1 to d1 bye-bye I'm just up
and these moves are easy they're easy
black has no way to crack the position
he has to pray his pawn runs down the
board somehow but in the meantime we're
gonna see a night of to get your queen
out of there
a king g2 and bring the rook and why
should I think I'm ever gonna lose no
that's out it's whether or not I win now
not whether or not I lose yes exactly
that Center has got a lot to say for it
oh my goodness is looking and it's easy
the worst part is it's easy
well white definitely as you're pointing
out Marissa well I definitely knows what
he's about to do he's about to play
Knight off to King G to bring his rook
into the game and it's it's that easy
it's not easy exactly so if I'm already
on the board a pound on the board I
agree that Queen d4 looks incredibly
logical you want to boot that Queen with
the knight more than you do
Bishop exactly and may I say something
just a quick point mm-hmm is in
preparation supposed to be good for the
guy who protects because we saw a nice
Giri
but let's I'll moves I do against em oh
yeah yeah you got I got my great prep
right yeah okay now we're looking at
Fabi great prep yeah and now he's indeed
rooms on the back that just shows you
guys don't overstate guys at home oh I
don't know the openings as well my guys
get good positions that's an excuse of
course you want to know your openings
well we get that but don't over estimate
the value of opening play make sure you
know how to play chess okay
make sure you got your middle games on
your end games tight your defensive
skills right really focus on that get
decent positions you don't have to get
winning positions just get decent
positions obviously don't have bad
positions all the time but even at the
2800 level you can gift someone great
prep and it still doesn't necessarily
mean that they're going to win the game
right and in fact none mean and they may
even draw the game because we're
watching great prep Mike the result of
great prep might be 0 & 2 in this one
shotguns unbelievable a quick look at
the standings after our first result
Alejandro of yeah draw between amagiri
I'm Maxine moschella graph means that
MDL is currently the leader with two
points but of course out of all the
people that have wanting to have to kind
of expect at least one of them will
score half a point exactly
and meanwhile in each with one point out
of three not the weight if you want to
start specially with two whites out of
the first three we will be talking to
him very shortly here on NATO camera
Skype so stay tuned that will be very
nice to have him join us and again this
was a you know yesterday got lucky
yesterday he got lucky would that draw
yes and kind of restored some semblance
of confidence today he had a very easy
game I guess with the white pieces just
stop the stop the bleeding yeah it was
the first time that you know he wasn't
worse I don't any point of the game
right yesterday it was just suffering
the fur
game was a disaster right he rates back
his horse's ass okay let's just play a
normal game some a little bit of prep
against my opponent screwing Phil but he
never risk excessively even in the end
game it just felt like he could have
pressed a little bit hard I had the same
feeling to Fisher versus working night
and your kings faster before I felt more
like a weakness but he allowed him VL to
remember the night and after that it
seemed like a pretty pretty easy draw
enough an interesting game yeah we have
plenty of action left what's going on in
the other games well the the game that I
thought was in one of our tournament
leaders favored was the on an epic game
pretty much what we said loves if
Carroll decided that he had to play this
moose III if he wants to play a fight
because bishops take c2 is really on top
yeah this idea of Queen b6 I'm taking on
d4 it felt like out of nowhere right
yeah this is the nice tactic that we're
talking about anybody's joining is a
little bit late here if you play f5
Bishop takes c2 and you're thinking AHA
I got you I'm gonna win my I'm gonna win
a piece Oh Queen b6 is a cold shower
queen takes d4 check and one of whites
bishops on the dthe file is disappearing
that was why c3 not the army was played
not to move that white desired lets
blacks bishop back into the game but now
having said that how good is that extra
exchange it's it's an exchange it's not
the best and the reason it's not the
bestest that it's difficult to
coordinated your rooks on the G file you
would love to double them h6 is very
weak but let's go really quickly to
Yekaterinburg as we have our friend
onigiri streaming life from there hey an
inch how are you doing hello hello good
to see you guys good to see you and it's
a solid result today we were thinking
after two tough games it was time to
play a little bit more solid shots yeah
but it would have been nice to also win
to play chess and win but I don't know
I think Maxim probably played fine
because I was trying to find something
but I just didn't see anything I don't
know yeah two big experts of the groom
felled an inch what was the surprise
moment for you from the opening I know
you both are very very well prepared
groom fellow players you played pretty
quickly to the position I have on the
board yeah I mean I I don't know how
many options I have in my my analogies
and stuff but what I recall there was
that through d8 was played here by
Nippon machine and 97 I did not recall
but ok so 97 kind of took you a little
bit by surprise
yeah I mean maybe it's a move in my file
but I did not recall it ok take us
through what happened thereafter yeah
well I thought to be honest I didn't see
the issue so I mean now that I realized
that there were some issues like I
thought just castle yeah 96 we should be
too you know I mean I was thinking also
maybe we should beef is possible I
didn't see what happens after c4 maybe I
mean it's ugly move but you want 25 and
takes yeah yeah it feels like if I even
like I can suck the bishop like if I
could 594 a six maybe a five I don't
know maybe a crush yeah I just crushing
probably yeah I don't know what I was
thinking
now well the thing is it's not even that
I was thinking something it's just that
I didn't see the need for Bishop e5 but
maybe maybe it was necessary wow he can
make any other move like Queen e7 or d
4s in Bishop e2 but after Bishop e2
before if I had got Queen d7 okay which
I missed from Farian now I don't see
because after Queen e7 I have some ideas
of a five CD f5 but sorry Queenie sevens
the decent Queen e7 insanity yes
then it's okay if I don't know because
they should have three boots maybe a
five I should Bishop of study of 625
rook f3
I think he's God I think it's got g5
only move now or not maybe he's got 95
but he has he got 95 as well yeah 95
attacks to have sex box yeah no that
wasn't the thing now you have to go city
first sort of have five I thought and
then and then look 88 I thought yeah and
then I was wondering about a fight here
[Music]
Bishop f3 I've got when I fix maybe
running ourselves
wow it is more fun than basically it was
all interesting and I was thinking about
it and then he got 27 and after Queen d7
f5 he just takes Sun f5 so Maxie the
Queen dear fun huh yeah do I have to be
better but I didn't see how so then
finally I decided to just play the most
normal moves and see but I didn't think
the same game is anything the problem is
that he's got night a4 so if I played
with the three rock g8 actually don't
yeah Ruby 3d aids if I go king after
he's got an area for I think and if in
this moment you had started I don't know
with rook a3 yeah okay three
I thought about let me tell you what
bothered me maybe can I go look d8 -
yeah don't you let me consolidate at
least maybe night somewhere yeah maybe
g3 yeah still pressure a looks like the
rook and Bishop my
or something okay wait second maybe I
should be yeah I was something was
bugging me but I don't recall what it
was to be honest fair enough fair enough
I just wanted to ask how are you feeling
in Russia how do you feel in this very
very strange times that that that that
are happening
Anish you feel comfortable there well I
mean to an extent I think there is
probably no better place right now to be
in then here because everywhere else
really people pretty much stop their
activities you know right and they have
to stay home and there is no much to do
or other than watch this tournament it's
like an island where life happens it's a
little bit like these TV shows like Big
Brother yeah it's like you are there and
the rest of the people are just watching
it 24/7 don't do anything else it's the
feeling I get because is of course it's
not also for us it's also different I
mean you feel you know with all the
doctor checks and sometimes can be
pointed out irrational reactions to to
things you get a bit more more worried
but compared to the rest of the world
probably you know you leave a small
snore I mean as normal as you usually do
you prepare you eat you play but yeah
it's different even we even stopped
taking walks and even I feel
uncomfortable going to the gym because
there are so many people you know using
the stuff whereas usually I wouldn't
hesitate and definitely enjoyed all the
5-star facilities and now I am really
cutting down on things right because I
feel you have to be responsible so
towards organisers they are trying to
make this work and we should also
explains try to make this work well I
had a question on each started to bring
back a little bit of a painful memories
was making the point that you had this
awesome preparation against Yong and it
really backfired and now we see Fabi
also with an incredible preparation and
it looks like it might also backfire
yeah yeah it's a it's a thing it's
normal I mean I
new this idea that Fabi played and I
know a lot of fun ideas but I don't
always there to play them because what
you do is you raise the level of
complicity and you do have an edge over
your opponent but it's not so big and
sometimes maybe you don't feel like I
mean my gimmick and to be honest the
unreacted just incredibly well he
actually equalized and equalized in a
way which I didn't really find natural I
didn't recall pretty much and then okay
I should have still held the game but
the fact that he didn't collapse it was
already very impressive and dink as well
well you've got these players who react
to know this quite well I mean dink he
just plays how he see he thinks is the
best I mean there are players would be
scared to leave the screen on f5 in our
out of play and they would try to let's
say after Bishop see took windy to c5
they would predict maybe the e3 much
more timid try to weather the storm and
then he just goes or what he thinks is
the best as if he plays an amateur and
the guy makes mistake it's okay I'm
gonna find show so yeah then if it has
such an approach then game becomes
double-edged and yeah it's his own fault
because I mean this move h6 that he made
that is degree really not in the spirit
of the position now I mean you're I mean
even I mean you're supposed to be two
points down and you're supposed to do
something dynamic but you should not be
it's not the moment for h6 now it's a 6
b5 who makes more sense immediately 6 is
just I mean you should not be losing any
time I guess I'm in particular
particular particular comfort because I
also saw the computer evaluation today
so it's very easy for me than just to
say that being said even without the
computer valuations for a player like
rabbit it is a strange maybe at some
point that h6 rook somewhere ok Jeff
Ruby g5 maybe it was his idea it was
maybe concrete but still it's it's not
really in the spirit of the position
actually
here acknowledged six I really like this
position I thought maybe rookie five
though I didn't see a follow-up I
assumed he memory will find something
right we are not playing if I before
even taking the bishop that's a better
way of continuing what is the difference
if you you keep attacking Knight f4 I
think but then you know what is the
frequency three yeah how could you three
here a problem with my prayed or not
can I sacrifice the Queen you can try
bishop before yeah yeah that's right
I can also move the Queen of course yeah
but let's try to oh sorry
I can I also go I could go Queen h4
first instead of g5 we liked yeah and
then we'd you three and then Chuck King
f1
I don't know quidgits Quincy 323 are
trapping yeah Queen you all right and
here the night h5 Bishop deformities
so I don't see the Irish we wanted to
thank you so much for joining us it was
very very kind of you well you sacrifice
yours that we mean and it's definitely a
double double edge position probably a
better Queen sacrifice than good luck
for the rest of the tournament
join us again Anish yeah thank you thank
you thank you got breaking news on this
a fact what's going on what is going on
indeed well this is just pure
desperation in the part of Bobby because
he sees that he's in big trouble the
prep did not work out and now he needs
to do something you played the move
Knight age five Knight to f2 chasing the
Queen out of there and then the bold F
for everything it seems under control
and Fabi said you know what I got a sack
I got to do something I've got to keep
some kind of Hope alive in this position
and I say except for with possible
threats I don't even see the threats to
be honest
King f1 played and now he is down a
piece he has one pawn for it the
position has gotten much more chaotic
the brook is still on h1 there may be a
chance to push the pawn he's playing
practically right now it is move 37 ding
has Diggler Marin has 7 minutes and 35
seconds to make three moves with 30
second increments coming we don't think
there should be any trouble at all to
make tacking
I'm thinking this is like an echo of the
game that we saw yesterday between fabbi
and peril where king h1 Rick t1 yes King
f1 that's reading g7 by the way and even
more so because right looks like he's
got he's only one pawn for the piece
right he's the one up the piece is white
it looks like Bobby's the same thing
right fine like everything is just
working in to dig Lorraine's favor right
now
the position is dead the position is a
guest bye-bye Fabio hope desperate
measures in desperate times but
unfortunately for him this is way too
easy that night on f2 now looks perfect
the coordination of the rook and the
Queen the bishop right now is irrelevant
everything is covered
there's no attack anywhere and by the
way an a4 be wary you can't even get
that going because they might just take
your opponent before I said what are you
doing exactly this one is dead lost his
dad lost it isn't exactly right well
thank you Maurice let's go very quickly
to Varco and there's some chess insights
for us well we take a very small break
alright some tricks and traps in a Slav
exchange variation so let's start with
d4 d5 c4 c6 all of Slav and exchange
variation is considered that it's not
very challenging but I believe there's
still a lot of tricky ideas that the
block should know how to play against so
Knight f3 I have 6 93 96 Bishop f4 and
here black has a few options one is to
play a 6 e 6 and Bishop f5 so I'll show
you how to play against all of this
lines so let's say a place is 6 you will
play III Bishop d6 Bishop g3 and now if
Castle you take back with the pawn
opening up the H file councils Bishop d3
and here you or they have some
interesting ideas on h7 and for example
if it's not careful and plays a move
like b6
now this book is already losing here you
have Knight e5 attacking the knight on
c6 Bishop d7 and now you have a nice
idea Bishop takes h7 check if Knight xh7
you play queen h5 threating made on h7
if the knight goes to f6 queen a
checkmate
if rook e8 then you will play Queen f7
check King h8 96 mate after Bishop age 7
if black decides to go King h8 you can
play Bishop c6 check King to g8 and now
a very nice finish with Bishop takes f7
Luke takes f7 and now deflection look H
a sacrificing the rook after King takes
Knight f7 for King
you can get win and winning so of course
v6 is a really bad move here but it
happens after I've seen this happen in a
lot of blitz games my students won many
games in this line as well so black
needs to watch out so maybe it move like
h6 here it's better so just remember
when you play a six III Bishop d6 you go
play Bishop g3 and if capture you take
back with the H pawn the other line I
want to show you is if he plays Bishop
f5 the most natural mode you play III
now II 6 you play Queen b3 now you're
putting pressure on b7 and it's not so
easy to defend against this threat so
you have to know the theory here for
example I'll show you a few ways that
black and lose here immediately
so Queen d7 for example natural move
defending the pawn but now this move
loses so very strong Knight takes d5
attacking the Queen and if capture on e5
here it's very important to take back
with a pawn actually because if you take
back with the bishop you're gonna give
block time to play the move a six and
stop Bishop b5 and if you play the
Bishop b5 right away then he can bring
the same night back to c6 and blocking
the pin so you will take back with a
pawn attacking the knight and as soon as
the knight moves you will play
devastating this should be five pinning
the Queen and when acquitting the game
basically so Queen d7 loses after 95 I
mean maybe he can't play Queen see it
but after looks upon it's a really
really bad position here there's gonna
be a lot of pressure on us e-file so
let's look at other options for example
b6 is really bad as well it just loses
to Bishop b5 look c8
five winning the piece on c6 and another
option if he plays Knight a5 this loses
to Bishop e5 check if you go 97 Queen a
for putting pressure on d7 and now it's
a six you go to capture on d7 Queen text
e7 and queen takes a five winning the
piece
so again it's very tricky here it seems
very simple and symmetrical but here
black should play Bishop before and
that's pretty much the only move here
another alternative is Queen b6 but
after Queen takes B 680 xp6
Roxy 1 white is slightly better here
so now let's take a look at the last
line with a 6 here is very important you
start with rook c1 because if you play
III that will allow Bishop before pin so
you don't want to play that so Bishop f5
you will play it three is six and now
again a very tricky move Queen b3 again
the same idea putting pressure on b7 and
here it seems like Queen b3 it's not a
good move because black can play Knight
a5 but if it does that you have Queen a4
check if it plays b5 90s b5 context
before we should be 5 check if you go
King g7 it just leads to the maid going
before
26:26 mate and if you clean 97 there are
a few other ways to win but I like this
line with 95 attacking on d7 if knight
c6 Knight x e6 rook takes a 4 we can
take on d8
takes a to rook c8 and now if black was
for the rope there okay one check King
be to work takes h1 that leads to the 96
mate and the other option here is to
play Bishop before check for example to
try to castle but you just taking f3
look B to check King f3 now again the
threat is 96 check so you have to castle
and now simply Bishop takes these 7 and
white is other piece if there's Bishop
before change in G 3 so so this is
something you look into against the Slav
defense
I like the exchange variation and I hope
you can use some of this tricks to win
some games and thank you and we'll be
back after the break for the round 3
coverage of the candidates tournament
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back to round three of the
candidates 2020 and we already have a
couple of results we had seen that
onigiri fast drawn with maxima paragraph
and triolic central has done the same
with the Omni poetry but what a sharp
draw that was and a huge miss for Hiral
Alex & Co I mean II think so as well
absolutely just we could go to that
moment
Yaser where maybe there was a failure to
really understand the position he made a
brilliant rook sacrifice I I have to
give him all the credit in the world
this one Queen e2 by okrill
saying hey you want my rook you can have
it but guess what this Bishop on c2s
pardon me this bishop on a4 is out of
the game it's hitting c2 but that's all
that's happening and he played this so
nicely right up to this moment we were
looking at move like Knight takes c6
Queen g4 ended up being actually quite a
strong move right but they had to
recapture with the coupon is fine oh you
like that okay g6 and this was the key
moment where Kirill just misses Bishop
takes g6 pointed out to me by Eric Rosen
unbelievable look at this following
continuation is just gorgeous
okay take on g6 I take on e6 that's a
hawk Osito how can see took Queen e7 is
the best move there's other ways but
Queen c6 check now you'd have to defend
that rook by moving the king and now the
brilliant h5 blowing open the cover of
the King know that if you take and
rookie three white wins concept you're
even oh you just don't have a way to
coordinate here black it's lost in this
position huge missed by Carroll Alex
anko he was given the opportunity to
take on g6 computer said completely
crushing that's a beauty it's a beauty
oh my goodness i 2800 chess Maurice you
were talking about it this opportunity
says you give this to fire you give this
to dig Loretta give this Magnus oh
you're bad but if you give it as a
tactical exercise it
but then because they know Oh Maurice
that would have been sweet that is a
stunner blowing the tournament open yeah
Bobby dropping you see you see Carol in
this case Knepper would have dropped
right and Grizz shook looking to put
some damage on Wang Hao also a leader in
the same round that would have been
absolutely incredible
I think MB I was running out of here
[Laughter]
with my draw I'm happy with that and we
should point out this position after g4
a six was played and now the move h5
look at how he's milking this position
is Gris Chuck it's 31 moves however
despite the fact that he's got these
nice rooks he's got that the development
against the pawn remember it's the
echoing yesterday as well Wang Hao was
the one yesterday isolated queen with
the isolated queen pawn and the
secondary weakness that he was going
after as well against Geary and we're
seeing it here trying to create another
weakness is Gris Chucky doesn't like
justice it's not enough this Knight is
holding back the two rooks just like
yesterday but hey another weakness we're
looking to create in the position so
that you can stretch the guy's defenses
he might be solid holding one but he
can't hold everything so that's what
he's trying to do the only - is he is
down after h5 it looks like King f7 was
played he is down to 153 on the clock
with nine moves to go so no I mean it's
a stunning it's a stunning fact that
Grichuk is down on time Wow Wow who's
ever thought of that storyline but
nevertheless we know he's of tremendous
blitz player and he's going to try to
make some moves and get going I think
you'll find 86 g6 as a natural move you
better find something because at 156 on
the clock well he did play a three so
let me not change anything just yet play
this move a three how many of those kind
of moves will he find however in this
situation still if he wins this game
Bobby goes down well how it goes down
we'll find neppo and
and Maxime clearly in first after the
round is they're both sitting at two
points with the rest date with what a
topsy-turvy district jumping good trick
will jump up into the lead and that is
what I'm talking about that is a
wide-open tournament Topsy turn I mean a
leader huge difference in why he had one
different event I just wanted to go back
to this game of Napa's for brief moment
because we didn't see the finish yes we
saw a gorgeous may be right but when we
had left it we had more or less left
adhere career played king f2 covering
the g3 square making it awkward for
black to double up on the Chi file and
just saying go ahead do something what
are you gonna do
well Napa was thinking thinking thinking
he said I don't really have that much to
do I'll try a5 and krill said okay I'll
take that and I'll take that give me
that one too no said Napa this is my
whole concept I want to come down here
Queen a to I'm hitting a bishop I'm
trying to get at your King and Grill
said okay I've got the answer you go
ahead and take my bishop and I've got a
perpetual check for you all beautifully
set up and that was how the game ended
that's a crazy game really you know I'm
addicted to my phone
I'm social media all the time and I've
seen several posts in since the game
ended but I keep saying if you can't
find Bishop takes g6 you just don't
belong in this stage how would you
answer that yeah well you put yourself
in that situation and if you find Bishop
g6 you know you've got my respect that's
a great great sacrifice seriously I mean
I thought that was everybody sees the
sacrifice yes no question you see that
the check to see six and king f7 what
your age five that diet move and
followed by rookie three no that's 2800
yeah
I mean that is really really different
but on the other hand this is the
candidates we're not look exactly play
or a great fight we're looking for the
Challenger of Magnus Carlsen got to be
one of these eight and the guy who plays
that well at the moment right I mean you
come up with that concept you you're
getting a lot of respect that is just a
nice nice game to drop real yeah we are
talking about this position right
because Bishop takes g6 isn't theirs
rookie Europe GA - you've got a calcula
no no you can't calculate look GS friend
okay but let's let's be real first of
all you do have to it's not Bishop g6
you have to see was h5 its h5 exactly
all right you see Queenie ZZ Queen c6
he's gotten there he saw I will say he
saw this in g6 right immediately his
brain when Bishop g6 so you want to
trash the guy all right first of all he
probably saw this should be six he then
looked at Queenie sixes so Queenie Samy
saw the check the King moves and he
probably thought rook to e3 at once go
ahead put it on right so we're talking
this position he got this far no
question got this far and he said we
don't c6 sorry I'm sorry I put the queen
of the wrong square my fault Queen c6
King up and he saw this move everybody
plays rook e3 everybody plays rook III
yeah you said I see work III so now he
goes all right so my attack is gonna
work with the rook here and the rook f6
but what if he moves his rook over mows
a rock over let's say we make a move
like this one check and we get a check
we got to move our acquaintance and he
moves this cape yeah all right now
where's my attack right Maurice my home
I'm a route down my tax did they're just
going to see two especially and we're
and I have no attack I don't even have a
move like I don't know what to do right
all right so let me go back
something's wrong all right I'm right
here our bed rookie three he brings his
rook into the game I don't have an
attack right and you're by the way
you're seeing this all the way back from
Bishop takes you right right right
you're not seeing from this position so
you saw you're looking at this position
in front of you and you calculate it
from here takes takes check cueing Queen
check King moves and now by the way even
if you were genius
enough okay I'm gonna give you credit so
you found this and you found this and
you found sorry why not keep dropping
the piece on that square you found this
right and then somehow you found this
let's say you were genus defy this now
you have to evaluate this sucker and say
actually there is nothing you calculated
all through his age fours that might
control a chi-square right here yeah by
the way like I didn't try h4 just put h4
and rook f3 okay all right
the King moves and now there's only one
way to win this position according to
the engines one way through five six
look at six is not it surprised it looks
like you should be crushing right engine
gives rook to c8 and looks like this
should be good it's just a draw but it's
a drop what you got don't you guys work
out six rupees so I gotta go back and
you got like come on let's be real folks
this is not easy stuff the instant now
by the way he has to see this from afar
in this position because it's moves
plate he has to find this move thanks
for giving me the square I really want
the g5 if you're gonna say h5 rook at
five six is pretty good
that's the candidates on the line you
wanted to sack the peas play kwazy 6 5 h
5 rookie 3 and against H 4 5 rook f3
rook F 4 even after all that black water
to avoid it could apply queenie 71 upon
you got your pawn sorry my bad you're a
genius right you know my bad I'm going
to castle in the next move we're gonna
keep playing and it's up no way just as
hard folks just too hard the engines and
make it look really easy yes I have an
engine here it's my job to have an
engine to keep us honest right all right
we're not gonna pretend that we see all
the stuff right we don't and then we're
gonna miss lines so we try to keep
analysis and give you something
instructive and the engine so that we
can be real we can be honest that was
amazing let's not analyze again you know
hindsight bias is real and when you look
at it in hindsight it's easy to say oh
he should have bloated to g5 bishop g6
he don't belong on the stage right he's
doing this thing and you got a draw
against nip oh let's see everybody out
there pulled that off I tell you I think
it easy
no let's just quickly check in on the
number 1 number 2 action well let's take
a look both ways that we have going on
half reach to move 40 okay so anytime
pressure for any of the players with
this we had left it when fabbi had just
sacrificed a piece desperate
that's our sacrifice but then we saw
this star move King g1 f1 getting ready
to bring this rook on h1 that hasn't
played any role into the game and by the
way when it does arrive it arrives with
force that we didn't find any move that
was better than Queen d6 rook g1
threatening mate in one
and once white starts having threats you
know something when ya white's material
ahead and it's white that has the
initiative retro Bishop b5 rookie 7 b3
by the way that just shuts down
anything on the Queen side right the
structures thought there's no longer any
group all type ideas of pushing the pawn
even if there was you here down at Pisa
exactly you've got one pawn for a piece
and this knight on f4 for what it's
worth
isn't it doesn't have any body helping
it this looks the lonely night right b3
by the way was moved 40 so yeah so he
said I love to leave making time control
remember what happened 20 moves into the
game ding was down to 16 a wonderful job
I mean after reading two games covering
here in such a sharp position being able
to just bring the Thunder just match the
place a put the Queen on at five
don't take any drawers just try to keep
the game going
yeah he knew he needed to win this one
when he's done it but it's so easy there
was some stuff in the middle
all right that stuff in the middle was
what the heck is wrong in Fabiana
886 a couple of waste moves where Queen
b6 Queen three look good but court
wasn't quite good she too played a six
b5 right away foul
there's some blame here blame oh for
sure right and and that blame is Fabi
not playing the way he should have
played this could have been two and a
half half you tuner do you know what
happens when probably starts winning
games in a row I know we know what
happens he could have won this game and
the tournament the narrative would have
been Fabiano history yeah we can stop
now we don't have to keep playing
because we know what this guy's gonna do
what a disastrous performance by him
give credit to ding Lorraine by the way
he's still at minus one after this win
he's still gonna be a minus one this
doesn't mean you know it's a comeback
time but at least he starts to bleeding
because minus three he literally could
have packed his bag could I have a
special request could I go home you know
exactly but so this is huge for him to
make this this play but Fabi in that's
the storyline Fabi collapsing with a
move like eight six inches playing weak
chess and allowing his opponent to
consolidate and now who's gonna win the
game by the way the the rise of one
player Chinese fortune is maybe the
deficit of another but take a look at
the exciting news in this game mmm-hmm
rook e8 h six now a three might be a
tempo loss we say the same line as eight
six verses in the Fabi game because this
move by waiting just one tempo and
allowing the move rook to e8 83 I'm just
go back allow this rook to come on this
fight he said what's the point
well after you played g5 94 check
appears on the board out of nowhere
Wow the point being that now pawn takes
allows politics the rook wasn't on the
line without a three would have been
here but now your bishop saying it is a
fork III thank you for the tempo so
eight three men had this flaw and I
believe we have Bishop takes after g5 94
stunner takes takes and now rook e1 on
the board and he's under a minute on the
clock to 12 minutes by Wang Hao formals
to make boy when you're in time pressure
anything could happen in this case for
Greece should that quiet move a3 which
by the way what is the real purpose
behind a3 looks like I thought he was
gonna go Bishop be me why a to okay this
should be one person should be one first
g5 is an actual thread right because d5
is threatened right that's right
also it moves away from the ninety four
idea because now your bishops not
getting it exactly but everyone was a
more multi-purpose move I felt yeah a3 I
get it but there should be one just
seeing more logic Oh a three you get
after you look at you say what's how do
we justify a three just say the same is
when you see eight six you say well how
do we justify this move yeah take away
the g5 right you need to give a reason
we're looking for a narrative Bishop a2
it could be that he just needed to make
a move and he makes the move makes a
quiet move the way Fabi made a quiet
move and it turns out these two choir
moves will cost two points potential
release maybes a point a half that it
will cost because a point for Fabi well
four five is very strong I mean we keep
saying the far we had Initiative five
had initiative that's great in every way
you've never had a win that's be very
clear about that right thing where I was
playing like a boss yeah I'm amazing
the guy nobody even if he draws though
even if he just drove my point is that
we've been saying probably fire Fabi but
at no point that they make a mistake I
mean he just kept playing amazing
he kept every blow Fabi took at him he
kept finding good moves finally good
moves he reached the position where okay
it was complicated it was still
complicated and I think that even the on
each line that he showed us that was
still really weird at no point was the
only run worse exactly even from a
position where perhaps he was a
complicated who says a dealer couldn't
come by back and still I'll play him
hard probably played some of the better
moves agreed
I mean he just played like a boss yes
Bobby didn't follow it up it felt if I
can use the tennis analogy for a second
dorka [ __ ] he kept returning the ball I
mean that was a great hit I was about to
say does Abby have any chances right now
this take on f3 know this looks dead
that this move regret it we're Greta
bilasa slips the event one another slip
and you're ending that you can bet Chris
trick is sitting there going what is
wrong what the heck why did I play this
move a 3 you can't just get in time
pressure and get away with it that's not
every single time get in time pressure
and get away with it that's just a
disease that God has he because his
whole career has been built on that and
yet he's number five in the planet right
with with this time pressure issue that
he continues to play so well I mean he's
a genius and yet he always hits himself
in time pressure and slips like this
will come and now of course wang hao is
gonna be very happy as his fortune is
quite high as well he'll draw the game
it looks like and we'll still be look at
how it might continue because it's it
right right you three looks kind of
force otherwise you lose upon okay then
rook d7 if we can look at maurices okay
we're now being King of Great King f8
they want to take on e because rook c2
is a threat no no I wanted to say come
b7 I wanted to analyze immediately
immediately
come in here well we can look at it in
your board I guess alright inch pin
check okay I'll do it on my board will
take on f3 check it's kind of an echo
thing that's going on here right about
this I play king of one right I want to
play route b6 and say okay your stuff is
kind of hanging up late I mean there
must be a way but what about your
partner but this that gave us what I'm
wondering
rook c5 rugby six you take on the chief
well if I do that I'll take on g6 and
I'll take on how you'll just take on
beets just not enough you're running out
of firewood but you had another idea
that you wanted to show sorry I know it
was wrong XP salmon oh okay sorry
nobody refuted it soundly a3 and again
the whole difference and we were
mentioning it but I just really wanted
to show it on the board is right here if
you wanted to play a3 and Bishop b1 and
Bishop a - you were explaining to me
Alejandra that you should start with
Bishop one in just sidestep because I'm
94 ideas I'm very direct and I was
thinking now I can actually take on g6
and play g5 and that will capture upon
on the next move like if I take on g6
right away and then what's the
difference right because we can't take
on h5 I think in any case what we're
talking about is black actually has to
it has to stop you with g5 but I like
keeping the pawns of life in this case
because here I have an extra an extra
pawn on the h5 square it makes the
position a little bit wider Bishop g6
might be an idea of black ever goes h6
and you probably will go h6 at some
point I like keeping the pawns alive
I don't like taking on g6 okay so Bishop
e1 e1 and after g5 you just then want to
play a3 and say okay now look I've
doubled my rooks right d-file
aren't I happy okay but what if he what
if he defends this ball no I'm not
saying that you know k h6 Bishop a2
look see - this is play yeah yeah it
it's it's a game yeah that's all it is
but okay we're going through on that
line I see that on our half taking on f3
followed by route d7 check by Chris
check okay just a second let me catch up
with the big game
rookie one takes one of three rookie
seven obviously only move King f8 and
this is the current position okay
well and this is where we're expecting
what takes B seven although there are
other moves right rookie egg first
should make some kind of draw exactly
you can in any case it's it's connected
with this idea that I'm gonna take this
pawn I work h1 actually threatening
checkmate never about idea whoa never
know if you'll miss it
alright rook h1 yeah okay but I can just
play oh I can't play King J you're
actually gonna double on the seven
rookie seven rookie d8 maybe look if you
played example a rook h8 and I just got
a much better version because you'll get
the same situation then my king is way
off on yes okay that's the kind of lose
all the time I know you need it like
that subtlety that the sudden shift to
the King what do you play here and the
same yeah but your Kings on h8 I'm sure
but but it's a lady for rook g5a for the
ideas that will play b5 and your king
stuck on I mean I might be a draw but if
I get d5 and you take I play a 5 a 6 a 7
you can't stop the pond so you have to
play b5 you have to play a 5 I'm a
rookie 7 you're asking an awful lot out
of my position your pawn down a 5 and
probably says right thanks ok might be a
draw I understand I understand Wow
it was played instead of rookie 77 by
the way unless he has something very
concrete I'd rather not the guy having
double rooks on the seventh and I'd
rather see your your single rook endgame
right maybe he's already evaluated this
to be a draw itself with the rook on h8
I have another by the way the pawn on f3
is still alive if black ever gets rook
f8 and rook C to check in the position
we might see it because I think Chris
Kirk has taken on b7 he took him be
second instead of doubling a fade I'm
sure that he has a great idea so it
turns out by the way it turns out in
this position yes Lee this position is
drawn after this there's no pole mating
concept right okay this pawn is covered
you you can't just you're always gonna
be in this situation so I check where
are you gonna put it you're gonna put it
back here because you go here you trade
it off you have to go back here and then
you can just go back it's actually how
do you make progress right you don't
need an engine to tell you this is a
simple drill you can't make me because
you you have to go check and move the
rook and then what you're one file short
right I mean yeah you need to magic you
need I think you need you need to be
here already you mean you need to be
standing here with you yeah in this
check you have to go that way and not
this way
so I don't think it's even a file issue
here you need to have the rook all the
way over somewhere over here and then I
could guarantee the idea but like this
we've seen this many times the two rooks
by themselves simply can't do it by the
way just to interrupt you Maurice at the
last move of worship nine seconds nine
seconds typical I know after this but
okay rooks by themselves don't meet and
we know that unless they were truly by
themselves like you don't have any ropes
but in this case you just say and do it
just with the two rooks on the seventh
Mike has enough counterplay if he gets
this pawn that's why you probably grab
this one because this pawn will be very
happy
I'm just looking at this position agree
shirk just took on b7 rook f8
I like pass pawn I think kind of forces
the rook to the Sabbath and they will
have a draw you better give me a
perpetual check on your next few turns
yeah yeah otherwise because rook check
seemed like the end of the game right
exactly if one if black tries to
sidestep the draw with something like
rook live well here I'll probably play
Rick a5 through yeah you force maybe
[Laughter]
same thing we've we've seen this
mechanism too often there's no way to
make progress here exact just for either
side it's gonna be a draw rooks are not
enough you know the most intimidating
moment I saw as hard chess you you
mentioned Maurice you've got an engine
it was Roberta Sifuentes he was playing
in this man versus machine competitions
in Aegon and Roberto's in a rook and
pawn and game he's a pawn down and you
know he's really suffering and I'm
looking looking looking and Roberto
makes the move that I wanted him to make
he plays the move and the computer
operator says made in 47 mate in what
was it 40 in the world the engine screen
now this one Brooksie too many moves win
almost any more than giving away a piece
for no reason and now if I just play the
move Knight to c6 ok hoping his opponent
captures unlikely to happen and did not
go to move Queen back to e3 and you know
things are bad when the injured
suggesting your best move is queen up
for when you're down a piece
for a part and agent says trade Queens
only play Knight g5
alright so of course is his idea when he
played 96 I'm sure there's a great idea
in stage 4 we don't want to see what it
is tonight's gonna drop back to the
square do something I mean this feels
like a blitz game for most of us just
desperate just gonna go like this and
like this and like this and like this
you're gonna lose right that's really
how it feels you're down a piece for a
pawn you're defending your position now
right you're on the back foot you know
you're pointing almost a readership
because you realize you're down a full
piece the same kind of finish that he
had yesterday yeah against Carol where
he what he was up a piece and the guy
should have resigned and he embarrassed
him with Queen h5
he's kind of getting in that mode right
now down a piece maybe they should be
resigning but he's gonna keep playing
right until he sees the writing on the
wall he's got to feel totally
demoralized for what's happened I think
right about now from Robby's perspective
he's got a sitting oh I know I know I
screwed up I got it I did I did this
one's bad but I'm gonna be a 50% it's a
long tournament left it's not the end of
the world not it's not the end of the
world it's not a pandemic folks hope not
the end of the world exactly
I've got 11 rounds and I am the highest
rated player in this competition right I
just I mean the guy started with two
blocks as well you score 50% in the
candidates from the first three games
that's the way to think about it that's
the way there were two blocks not the
end of the world right now you place
number two yep
but I don't want to hear the data point
though that nobody has ever lost this
early and one of the candidates that's
right
Michael tall and 14 because it was able
to pull it off but but we don't want to
hear that right that's it that's the way
he's gonna have to look at this bad day
at the office horrible day at the office
but I'm still at 50% I'm not in a hole
the guy who beat me is still behind me
exactly
I got a lead on him so don't Lee you're
not partying in the streets just because
he won a game let's be real so it's
still okay yeah a couple of thoughts
going on in my mind regarding this game
the first one is that I'm yeah no I
meant the fabbi game if I'm Rustem Kasim
Jean off and I'm sitting there going
dude I gave you the greatest piece of
analysis of the world and look what you
did with it and if I'm digging Lorraine
and I going to the candidates said Dean
I got really some great news for you
give me the good news first you're gonna
beat fabbi
the number one seed and the third round
that means I'm in first right you're not
gonna be first yeah I get to beat the
number one seed and I'm not in first but
Fabien 50% will be trailing the leaders
at plus one and let's just remind right
yeah just by half a point I have a boy
they just said plus one they're not
nobody is collecting points and running
away with the event so he's not sitting
in isolation we talked a lot about
momentum tomorrow they have a rest day
that's what I wanted to say think about
what happened three very eventful rounds
to start the church and I mean my
goodness and you know take stock it's a
tremendous way to start it arena so many
things happened right in those games for
all the players I mean Curia losing one
game but having that chance against Napa
he's gonna be six yeah I mean I know
that guy's not gonna like not look at a
phone he's gonna see all the comments
he's gonna really has that pressure
playing in his homeland playing all his
fans while his friends watching and
everybody's gonna be like well Bishop to
60 right yeah
we have neppo who is pretty much playing
his stylee's yes very nipple thing right
running down his opponents cloths
playing sharp playing fast not playing
double edged chips but double edged
against Gary just doing a tremendous job
I think Maxime is also going to be happy
with this tournament you hugged
converting against English I know
especially especially playing number one
number two in the first three rounds and
tying for first
that's excellent thank you you having
alright not great event obviously losing
his first game quite a quite a blow
right Bobby just incredibly topsy-turvy
playing destroying Alex anko having this
proud getting crushed thing Lorenz
saying I'm back in the tournament you
know let's take a day focus whatever it
was distracting me it's its new event i
won
let's keep fighting right the thing that
really stands out from me is in these
first three rounds I think we're seeing
it every every year round fab ease
playing the most sharp openings doesn't
matter he's black or white he's not
shirking from any kind of complications
in the fact he's trying to force a great
deal of Congress he's gonna get over it
quickly you know there's a there's an
old saying you live by the sword die by
the sword right you come in with Hackham
destroy stab them openings right the guy
is a knife to he's gonna stab back and
if we talk about the Macao tall event
that he won I mean he lost the first
game won the next one lost again won
again it's like back and forth he had a
topsy-turvy way he was at 50% after five
rounds and then with two losses on top
of it two losses now you might have said
well five draws you wouldn't even talk
to the guy he'd say oh yeah he's having
a boring tournament at the moment he
could come back at any moment this guy
had two losses in five rounds and then
he started hammering three wins in a row
and then really put up some ridiculous
numbers so the reality is this is a big
result as you pointed out Alejandro
Diggler n will feel better he
you'd feel a lot better if he was at 50%
right but you feel better about himself
like okay let's take this one game at a
time
Bobby will say okay I retracted but
after clearing my head I'm still Fabiano
Caruana hmm and he will look and say I
mean if you looked at this score this is
the current scorer in the tournament
you'd say don't think about the fact
that Bobby is going to lose the game
just say this is the current score you'd
say fabi's a half a point behind neppo
and maxime okay so what's the problem
normal percent normal situation in a
tournament right that's what you say you
say okay what's the big deal you see
ding the restaurants always got zero
that's pretty bad and then you realize
oh are appending so then the rain will
move up to one he'll join a group of
players at the bottom right
Bobby's half a point behind the leaders
who cares
like what this is no big deal let's be
realistic so that's the kind of tough
mindset you have to have in a tournament
though that individual games upset you
especially round three don't let that
happen
yeah easier said than done right Richard
game okay so let's take a look at what
higher when when we have left it we have
just seen rook takes p7 by Sasha check
immediately not rook FA but simply check
immediately it was later approved and
rook age 44 anywhere else trying to
understand that one and well they're
still playing I think it's a draw two
verses to look upon games and draw yeah
I mean some incredibly high drawing
percentage the whole idea of rook h4 is
any rook check I think is intended to be
met by rook f4 that's the idea of rock
h4 y will have all the optical pluses
I've got the rook on the seventh those
optical pluses all the obstacles but if
if we were to say alright listen I got a
hundred bucks on this yeah exactly
no takers no takers I always made also a
couple of well desperate moves okay we
left it here after h4 Knight f7 the
knight is kind of doing a little I got
$1,000 on white queen c5 nice move
first of all defends of the bishop
tempos against the rook by the way don't
forget that rook takes f6 is on tap as
well so that's what we call a triple
threat right there the rook is hanging
the bishop is defended and the pawn on
f6 is hanging that's a resigns that's a
stop the clock yeah that's harsh
I mean I don't what can what move do you
make no I think well I mean what can I
say about ding Lauren I mean he was he
had his back to the wall he's coming
into this game oh and - and this guy's
just dropping bombs on him yep and he
just fighting he fights he fights Wow
absolutely I mean that's that's a great
game I mean it's just a great game my
thing there and there is no other way to
put it yes favi yeah you spoiled he
fumbled yeah yeah yeah brought in the
fire wasn't able to keep it lit right
but I mean he just played great chest he
really did
Wow you know tells me we talked about we
keep talking about it when we talked
about kitaru you know that when you're
at a certain level there things that
happen to you even if you're a star
player but you're not quite at that
highest highest level and in the moments
when you need to just find that moment
when Fabi walked in after beating him
and said yeah I like my position but you
know you should to play Knight f6
instead official taste these things like
the
the top layer is it this is how you
fight back this is what you do because
when you're playing against 2,800 the
fight that they put oh I got the
greatest prep in the world guys it's
it's amazing
mmm now what you get a fighting position
the oh man I thought I was better in the
endgame what do you get the guys still
fighting somehow he manages to play
something and this and book and the game
ends in a draw and say man what does it
take to beat these guys right their
defensive skills their mindset so
amazing so tough when it's hard that's
what those twenty in hundreds do and
that's what you saw a dingaling ring do
today it's very clear to him that he was
getting punched that he was wasting time
on his clock but that amazing mindset
I'm gonna keep Friday I'm gonna keep
fighting he's got to find all the moves
it is compensation that's clear I'd like
to have his position not my position I'd
rather is but I'm gonna keep fighting
and show me show me what you got
that is mindset that's toughness that's
a 2800 level how hard is it to beat
these guys how hard extremely difficult
we just found out today didn't extremely
different do you remember when you
remember when Magnus I saw a little shot
of Magnus there but what Magnus had that
position remind me the number game guy
alejandra you'll remember the game where
he was it was a Sicilian match London
when he was all over Fabi like all over
Fabi with the black pieces white 1/3 no
the game ended in a draw it was a late
it was little all game Sunday and it was
a late game it was a lady could have
played Queen g7 and no no no no no not
that game also not that game guys it was
a game where where he he had black it
was we had luck table no Magnus had
black and Magnus had this amazing attack
we're in the in the Kalashnikov in the
last game was it the 12th game was the
12th game where Bobby gets attacked
heavily and then - weirdly offers a drop
no no no it's it's before that games
before the Amy okay so I understand when
you're talking where Magnus sacrifice a
pawn on the Queen side favi can take it
but it it's really really dangerous at
that one yes yes yeah and then and then
Magnus has this amazing attack right I
mean I remembered hearing Judit Polgar a
quote later she said I don't even want
to look at wise choices
I just love black yeah look at this how
is he going to survive this it's Magnus
with the black pieces he's got a vicious
attack and Fabi playing like a
stone-cold gangster defended perfectly
like like Magnus was thinking what the
heck look in the position I have with
all this attacking chances all this play
the whole world was saying oh this is
all black Fabi looks like he's in
trouble and probably played so much like
a defender like you wouldn't believe he
just stood there and said I'm holding
this fort what does it take to beat
these guys and that's what Fabi faced
today he had a great position and found
out it's not easy breaking down that
great wall this is not easy
Thank You Maurice I still remember the
greatest piece of preparation ever it
was a World Championship match between
Vladimir Kramnik and Peter Lake oh no
marshal gambit Lattimer kramnik and his
team a huge team of players top top
grandmasters the world prepared a piece
of analysis that laço refuted over the
board
who are just joining us we've still got
two games in progress we're expecting
Fabiano to lose this game against one of
the pre tournament favorites Daniel
Aaron and well that just ding Lauren
returns to the tournament with such a
result right I mean while we're the
other game we're expecting a draw
between Grizz sugar Wang Hao Wang Hao
the seventh seed surprising everybody by
not only being tied for first coming
into today's game
well attentionally he could have been
just winning the tournament he would be
could have been a very clear first had
he won a games early in inferior
position today but yesterday what a
missed chance extra puts on a clearly
winning position against giri wasn't
able to convert but he's still up
Cleary will be his start I can't see him
losing this game it's already turning a
perpetual to beginning exactly things so
fascinating start to the tournament
we're still gonna have a bunch of
leaders tied up there and so we're gonna
have people at 50% and it's going to be
anybody's tournament exactly and we do
have a free day coming up tomorrow
everybody will take a much-needed like
where do we stand internal diagnostic
you know like what what is half a did
the first three rounds but this is what
our schedule Alexandre looks like for
the rest of the bars our rest day so
tune in tomorrow if you want some kind
of recaps but you want to go over some
stuff that we've already done commentary
but there will be no transmission
because the next game it game four will
be March 21st that's on Saturday and of
course sunday will have only round five
then Monday will have round six and
another break after that that's gonna be
the schedule throughout the event and
remember very very unlikely to have
playoffs on April 4th because there are
playoff matches but those only happen if
the mathematical tight breaks are all
equal and that's Maurice back over to
you because you want to make the point
about that world championship moment I
just wanna go back to it I thought it
was game 10 it is game it was intended
yeah it's this one here and remember we
were doing commentary on that's world
goes doing commentary on this and we had
this situation look at this position
that that Fabi had to face off against
you got pawns racing down the board
you've got the bishop hitting the rook
the King looks exposed a pawn is gonna
land on f3 this I mean this just looks
like pain
yeah you got a pawn on e5
congratulations what who cares this
attack does looks so tremendous and all
the variations is just so delicious to
analyze for black like this is who you
want to you do you really want if I said
victim you can have rider black quickly
quickly I got stuff going and it wasn't
the situation he played wrote g1 f3
Bishop f1 a trade the pawn got picked
off in the middle
look at these guys it looked like it was
raining down the board and and after
Queen to e6 Fabi still playing on this
side playing this way and Bishop d8
Queen e1 a trade rook b8 even here the
pundits were still liking blacks
position but somehow Fabi managed to say
no look at this I'm gonna get this going
trade it off Queens and after D 5h4 rook
c8 work a3 he had his own play as well
versus this position you can see the
rest of the game you even better watch
an old video of us doing commentary on
this and you'll see how much we liked
the lack but the engines kept arguing we
can defend but a human to defend this
yeah well if you were 2800 right it was
it was what these players do we see a
shot there of the two players from
London yeah it just it's just hard to
beat these players that's why so many of
the games and then draws and when you
get a great position sometimes you end
up losing and that's what happened to
Fabi today oh well what is happening to
Fabi right now it's a letter there you
can always see man in Russia and I thank
him I want to thank him for all the work
he did and for uh nigiri especially for
joining for us right now the game he's
the one setting us I put those
interviews exactly mullahs play by the
way he did not resign he played Queen d8
and allowed the smashing rook f6 I've
owned the board
I heard Bruce time I was going
downstairs with the towel and yeah stop
stop
he's getting taking too many shots this
is where we thought Queen c5 that was
hunter as it does defend the bishop it
attacks the rook and it unleashes a
chance for rook f6
he moves like Queens da Queen d8 I don't
like that I don't like psychologically
that he's still playing that's right
told it the guy play work f6 on you yeah
you know you lost the game you know it's
over accept it
just just take that inside it's over
don't let him actually play this move
this explosion in your position i I just
you know I hear you Maurice I hear but
how many interviews have you given where
the guy comes on and says I saw rook f6
and I wanted to resign of course he's
not going to get he did okay that's
that's injurious now but this is where
yesterday we're saying about krill that
okay now is a good time don't don't miss
your opportunity to resign he might have
missed it once or twice before we
finally caught on that's what I'm
thinking well you've definitely missed
it for less how about the super
embarrassing oh they're not even talking
about Queen before yesterday Fabi
playing Queen h5 let's be clear yes he
didn't like Queen takes GC I wanted more
in a chair he said no you should resign
and I'm gonna play moves that make you
feel real pain right this one that one
would have been yeah those are hurt
field I'm gonna keep playing moves like
five good enough naturally good enough
Wow oh boy oh boy yeah I was about to
say oh okay enough said our draw a game
between Grichuk that was the double rook
ending possibly keep this game going
I'm thinking on this move for how long
12 minutes after that's an indication
he's not ready to abandon his right
winning hopes why not why not what why
not think what could you be thinking
about here what are you talking about by
the way did you guys see the interview
yesterday he gave at the press
conference gray shark is always good for
he's talking about his game with Napo is
like you know he's sleeping during the
game I kind of woke up with and I only
had six minutes I really want to play
for a win I just like and then it was a
company buy a picture to wear Grichuk
really did seem to be some very very
nice meditative state yesterday I don't
know exactly what happened but I never
did something Grisha talked to him
during the game and then he closed his
eyes I actually don't spoke with him
yeah I have no idea what actually
happened Wow okay also there was a great
picture of them maybe we can get that
doing the elbow the elbow yeah right at
the start of the game you know but then
did you see how they finish the game no
with a handshake because you forget
completely forgot you're it's like a
mechanism now you finish and you move
you know well done well that's played
nice place okay but you totally forget
listen I don't think there's a problem
with a handshake itself the act of a
handshake doesn't cause you to get sick
right mm-hmm it's what you do with this
hand there at once it's already executed
the shakes you got you got it you know
you're contaminate you got like 20,000
viruses on your hand make sure after you
know one of those things where you shake
a guy's hand any you okay don't do that
you shake the hand
Hey wipes please and I'm sure our
bidders are ready boy they saw that
action as soon as he walked off
sanitized DUIs sanitize them they're
making light of it it's serious though I
don't think that I think a handshake is
not a problem as long as the very next
act is I got my Santa type I'm not
trying to you know be mean to you or
insult you or anything but I got to
sanitize cuz I'm right situation is okay
also also saying that by the way I mean
I hate bringing this up it just sounds a
little bit more bigger than you think
about it but they are moving each
other's pieces they're capturing each
other's pieces exactly so I thought the
same thing right if you if your hand
touches the piece you captured that's on
a hard surface and then I capture that
piece that's in my hand so that's like
shaking you got to be sanitizing right I
mean I'm thinking they're the cleanest
pieces of the before and after three you
making a move
I guess if well I I mean I can argue
that you sanitize before hands obviously
they're sanitizing beforehand the pieces
are clearly very clean so you sanitize
beforehand you make the moves so you're
touching the pieces but I figure your
hands are ultra clean but no matter what
I'm still gonna clean my hand yeah what
you're saying is wash your hands often
and you should be there's some guy in
the tournament hall whose only
responsibility is the game finishes I
why they got like industrial bleachers
you know coming in you know like they do
on the airplanes they're just watching
everything they're all over in taking
temperature twice before the game out
for the game well it was actually kind
of funny that
fabbi had caused you know a politician
if he alerted because he had 98.7 which
would have been ninety eight point six
which is range and then Maurice you you
shocked me by saying well 98.6 isn't the
new at noon
sigh because we were all looking at the
smartphone like night talk about an
article claimed the the average human
temperature that's considered normal has
dropped over the last ten years or ever
since we nineteen eighty seven point
nine and for more than a hundred and we
have at more than hundred years but
recently there we go there's a real
there's the very very politically
correct very woken everybody knows
what's going on in the world forty moves
later demand button yeah he's had that
for a while that's just that goes back
to Croatia with that exactly but this is
this is the new reality of course chess
players respecting that yeah you these
these good friends I think they're good
friends but is he is this drug or not I
don't know Russian word for the real
serious homeboy by the way he is not
being treated like a drug right now his
Fabiano Caruana he's continuing to play
the rook took and went back played rook
c7 Bishop c6 very hard to imagine Oh a
nice play a four so he's looking for
some well if you think with the bishop
if there's are so many disgusting things
that could happen to you and he sees the
pawns I mean literally I can give he's
not in this one but somehow in his in
his mind exactly like in my mind it's
better to stop and I collect myself okay
this is just a loss no problem and I
leave out of here I would have already
processed it during the game yeah that
was that was something I made sure I
always did during the game when I
realized I'm going to lose I'm not
walking away from the board depressed
I'm gonna sit there and say okay peace
but I think I've lost have already been
made I'm you know what's lost right so I
just go but so after that then it's just
a question of when do I resign I see it
this is a good time to resign so when I
realize like okay you got it
and I walk away go deal with it like you
know go just think about the next game
but it seems Fabi is saying
maybe he's made peace with it he's like
yeah what if I resign I lost so what if
I just make a few moves until it's truly
over I've already made peace with this
fact that it's the game is lost but
let's make a few moves what if the guy
blunders nobody ever won a lost game I
want a game by resigning so what if I
just make a few more moves so maybe his
mindset is he's already made peace with
it but it's just continuing to play just
to see okay so he's not feeling any
worse that the guy's bashing him in the
head because that's what I'd be worried
about I mean for like oh another hit
more than another one oh you got your
belly up to the chin no I wouldn't want
that to be happening to me but Bobby's
like no shame in just playing on some
more okay okay we have a couple more
moves in the great game with sure okay
their moves this is the four Roca ending
I've got to go sort it through there
just looking at that Fabian
that was the perpetual we left it before
that covers because rookie three you
have king of four right just like let me
point out what the perpetual is all
about is that it kind of goes like this
that I will continually harass the King
but now that the so what critic did
instead was now any check along the
third he's going to drop up but that
when L said okay you don't have a
perpetual but you don't have a prop on
alrighty six was played threatening the
pawn on g6 really defend that guy work
hard through the King the rook back to a
one oh he didn't play g5 check okay
sorry they won't play rook a1 instead
she six was played okay and then he
played the move King h8 come on this is
pretty dead yes right never gonna mate
yeah okay so definitely that that and I
think we are actually finally gonna get
a professional goes for cage six what's
played King g8 Brooke g6 yes okay this
is this is a good time to give it a
resting somebody should tell them they
can offer it a forty it is allowed okay
because that is the whole point the
players up to the first time control the
first 40 moves are forbidden to offer
draw of course through a perpetual check
or repetition to draw can be agreed but
it can't be offered and that will mean
that our remaining our lone remaining
game is this game where unfortunately
for fatties fans he's way behind in
material and he's been lost for quite
enough he's not a bishop and a pawn in
this position he doesn't have this beep
on though that maybe the guy might sleep
on it looks like ding lurin is paying
attention so we just played rook to g3 I
imagine b2 will be met by a very
straightforward work b3 and yeah I mean
yeah unless you can come up with some
miracle of miracles just now what I'm
hoping to see is you know you know you
put blitz you think I'm gonna have a
trick yes right I'm hoping to see
something that looks like a trick right
but I mean you're playing Tingler and
he's the type of player that won't allow
you to create a trick right he has his
position so much under control that you
just can't
out of nowhere creative I found a trick
you ready for this trick okay where is
this dumbest trick never watch this trip
here we go this is pure pure
ridiculousness easily because I already
see what's wrong with it okay but I'm
gonna show you this dumb tree this is a
blitz came true so where are we we're
here I'm gonna play beat you so the
other game isn't in a drawer I played
this move okay okay you take I yeah I T
right you take my pawn
okay ready for the stupid trick yeah I
take right I take with the king I know
you can take with the Queen a small
point no you take the game you take oh
oh no I lost my queen and here's the
funny part
you're lost
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is how bad it is guy could play
that move and give its Queen back so
yeah it's it's bad news it's bad news or
g3 ruling on this position okay and by
the way a draw once again has been
agreed so that doesn't mean that Wang
Hao is sharing the first place our
seventh seed continuing to impress yes
and we are just waiting for the
handshake really or available touch
between digging they're in anaconda
because this this is exactly four
players enter today's competition type
refers after today's competition three
players that will be tied for for one
gets knocks out down just a bit
probably with 1/2 points and he'll
remain there meanwhile Maxine Bashar
like Ravi on Nepal yashi and one cow
will have two points after their drawers
Grichuk is still in 50% being the only
player to have all draws in the
tournament so far
I don't like theory and qlex tank will
have two drops each and have lost the
game therefore putting them on one point
and England will be joining them as the
only players so far not to have drawn a
game all decisive for him and but a
negative score 1 & 2
he'll have one point after today in well
just a second we assumed but we've been
saying that for half an hour yeah
but before we go into the rest day of
the 12 games that have been played in
the first three rounds we've been
treated five to five decisive even the
drawers have not been dull I mean that's
very interesting yeah maybe the Giri
game today it was something that was
obviously in the back of our minds
relative to the other games going on
because they didn't capture our interest
the way that Bobby's position was Alex
anko's position was but that was
actually an interesting game on its own
no question about it and I'll go back to
her to my own self thinking that that
end game I really have the feeling that
you know MBL was given a pass like a
niche might have been able to press
today and he didn't he didn't it also
felt that some of the variations that I
need she was showing after Bishop b5
instead of playing Bishop e2 now they
were in true those were fascinating he
sacrificed the bishop through a pawn
forward yeah he felt that game left a
lot on the variations table like that
and I agree and yeah an issue was again
he was kind of berating himself that he
didn't play Bishop b5 yeah
no I like the Bishop b5 that that would
have been nice I wasn't really nice and
again we want one game remaining we had
a very very eventful round this one game
remaining was just a remarkable game
because of an incredible piece of
preparation on I don't even know how to
describe it on the 3000 level yeah as in
a very standard opening the Slav defense
a semi Slav defense
fabbi came people armed with an entirely
new concept he played the novelty six e
5 amazing which put ding Lear in on the
back foot and ding Lauren was just
spending all kinds of time to withstand
fab ease assault and fabbi was a
dropping bomb after bomb after bomb and
the amazing thing was with like 20 moves
left in the time controlled Engler and
was down to a mere 15 16 minutes and
then something very shocking occurred
that me didn't follow up his prep we
were singing his praises and saying you
know like he's doing really really well
yeah an itch came on our show after his
game and he cited this move as well as
we taught ourselves like 86 what's that
it doesn't belong right when you have
such an attack it just feels strange
because it's a basic mistake right you
have under the initiative going on you
need to keep that pressure dynamic yeah
and h6 gives such a crucial tempo there
was this wonderful
I was raised with the Soviet annotation
the Soviet Way of annotation and the
Soviet way of annotation was h7 h6
question mark it doesn't fit the needs
of the position and we were looking at
Queen B for like let's hit that pawn
right away we were looking at a 7 a 6 B
7 B 5 something very explosive we're
looking at rookie 5 that fit the needs
of the position and after this like the
loss of 2 you look at the entire game
yeah and you tell me what at age 6
accomplished with hindsight not anything
I would I would take pride in nothing at
all right right yeah I mean and by
playing just really really careful good
solid moves and by the way I thought
that this was particularly impressive I
think a lot of people and time pressure
would have played Queen G to gain gain a
move or two on the clock no ding the
princess no I got you I know what I'm
doing I'm moving my queen I'm playing
Knight f2 your boss got nothing exactly
and
fabbi said okay I'm gonna set up some
kind of desperado similar instead of
three F for nobody believes you and you
know go ahead make your desperado
sacrifice in this very to me star move
King f1 King F Wan I mean that just is
so that really seals the deal right and
ever since then has just been a bunch of
moves that it's all been good it's just
downhill sailing for NB three - I mean
that just really kind of clinches it
just again a lot of just very very good
moves we had a couple more moves on the
board okay from where we left it
right I think after yeah here we start
thinking to ourselves throw in the towel
throw in the towel and we saw the move
look g3 yes Rick g3b - okay sorry I have
to refresh my board there you go okay we
saw route g3
yeah p3 96 takes takes four it takes me
to Queen f4 which I actually don't see
what it threatens I guess 94 94 yeah
yeah II understand and we've caught up
to the players yes that kind of thing
currently thinking what's the best way
to finish off this game right sure yes
94 looks like looks like PA and Quincy
turret movie any Queen c2 and and all
you can do is take on f2 but
yeah so it's not a threat I mean
obviously we can you know count the
material and sit there and say well is
it white like a bishop and two pawns up
but I suspect that this isn't just a +5
on the engines part I think it's
probably much more even than +5 what it
I mean come on this is I mean I strong
it'll probably start what's for tea
probably is really yeah there's no way
to evaluate this there's no reason to
evaluate this from a now the algorithm
starts breaking I mean yeah it's so bad
might start catching some smoke
[Music]
watch Ben Feingold I was playing in the
u.s. championship and it was a time
trouble and I was winning and it was
just getting better and better and
finally we reached time control my
father designed and Ben Feingold said
that after the game Yasser you know you
put up put put the the game into the
fritz engine and played it played it
through and I was plus 37 he said I had
never seen the Queen's being worth nine
points I think that's that's a lot of
Plus this looks like a lot of do you
think that Fritz I mean I'm not a
computer expert but I've heard really
good things about this it's pretty
interesting it's a basically a Leela
type of engine in that it doesn't copy
the way stock it's not they're not
really self-taught okay but they the way
they analyze is that they play each
other it plays itself millions and
billions of times right to figure out
which paths it should take and which
path it should eliminate okay similar to
Leela it tends to be pretty optimistic
about its chances right sometimes it's a
overly optimistic and end games that
other engines considered to be quite
equal but it does come up with some very
interesting ideas some unusual ones so
right now we have Lila and stockfish I
think are at the forefront commercially
available and just probably the
strongest ones as well but besides that
there's still Oh some other engines that
are interesting so you're saying like
that Fritz has like an arrogance factor
it definitely has an arrogance factor
yes there's a lot of engines that have
that actually a lot of grandmasters
really didn't like stockfish 10 and the
reason that stockfish 10 was really
shunned by the community is that they
didn't know it came with a new value
called contempt contempt is exactly what
it sounds it's an arrogance value saying
my site to move
is better and the reason it gives it
like an inflated evaluation the reason
being that to play other computers to
play on and not for so many perpetual
store for so many drawers not accept so
many three full repetitions
right it had this arrogance value to say
I'll play on because I'm playing right
and I pushed in right and it came with
this with this little yeah I mean but if
you said it 2-0 then it's fine it's fine
like it just continues as normal just
stronger than its predecessor but people
thought oh it's wildly changing its
opinion all the time I hate this engine
right and that was what it was that was
what it was okay I have a dollop of
contempt by the way speaking of contempt
there there's there could be some
gamesmanship going on here I think
there's clearly some gamesmanship we're
saying Fabi resign resign resign but
let's get in his chair for a second he
knows he's lost he knows it's been lost
for a while he knows there's probably
one in a million chance of a trick
coming out of this position and maybe
it's gonna be some ridiculous number
that's if you play you run the
simulation against ding Loren a hundred
thousand times there's gonna be nine
hundred and nine is like some ridiculous
ninety nine thousand nine hundred and
eighty six times when the game ends in a
win and is that fourteen somehow where a
rock falls in this head or right you
know he trips on the way to the restroom
and buses his mouth I mean something
ridiculous or okay most of times gonna
lose
is it possible though that he's thinking
in a fitness way as well I'm just
throwing things out there guys is it
possible he's thinking you know if I
keep playing that might hurt the guy
worked the guy right make him make him
lose a little something when he felt I
should have resigned a long time ago but
he's still making moves is he trying to
throw him off for the future in any way
because obviously the president he's
going to lose the game maybe there's
something else at work here other than
just inertia inertia we could have
explained five moves ago ten moves ago
this is not inertia right now he can't
just be playing
it just doesn't make any sense it has to
be some rationale he has I don't know
how what he will use but there's got to
be a reason why he's still continued to
play in a position that is clearly
beyond lost never young and jump in here
what do you think's going on
it's a top opponent for him it used to
be somebody that 5e was comfortable on
yeah the to zero score against it with a
bunch of drawers right now it's turn it
does that this is the moment it turns
the tables it was to to this is now the
3-2 was it the same cup where ding
they're in one that's really beautiful
really nice against fabbi beautiful this
is the third win in a row of Dingley
rheticus withdraws and Wichitas you mean
just three in a row in a row I might be
mistaken about this but I think it's
Norway in in middle of the this was the
lifetime coming in two days and you're
saying that basically fabbi through
their junior days was a - oh not even
that junior they're different they're
not a different generation but it didn't
play that much as juniors okay sorry
yeah but I think it was Norway was
middle of the year yes it was after
Zagreb that's important
it was then there were no classical no
classical events between them right and
now it's this one so three in a row I
might be forgetting some draw baby and
one of the grand Chester's are trying to
get my be any draws in not classical
Chester blitz but showdown no not
classical chess yeah Norway was followed
by the same field car in that case
that's three in a row this is the third
this is the thing the round victory
against Bobby in a row
there was no drugs he didn't play in
Tata Steel did England no I'm probably
didn't playing in the grand chest or
finals or anything like that right or
that there were just the the rapid a
blitz events yeah three in a row
did the England's become a very powerful
opponent for fabbi clear they didn't
play in the World Cup
No okay Fabi didn't even play that well
probably didn't play in the World Cup so
the grand Swiss no no sure I didn't play
well Paris so that's the reason yep
freezy no no that's a big thing right
that's a very big that's that's a start
of a big but sure definitely in one
calendar year beating a player three
games the three classical games that you
played with no draws especially when
you're number two and number three in
the world right it's a big deal and
somehow he seems to be having problems
with him and wonho
consoles of five zero against five yes
we say that it's a it's a junior day
some stuff like that they haven't played
in a while but it's not like one house
ten years older than exactly he is older
but not a generation generation I do
remember neppo having a lead on Magnus
Magnus was having a difficult opponent
in the problem the Qi and we saw some
changes but that was like one game right
yeah you know so I don't think you'd
make too fine a point about his being
weaker than a player II know you you got
yours I - Oh on you now you got me back
but I don't but but that doesn't explain
him this game though right now that why
he's still playing why is he still
playing because it's not gonna change
the fact that's gonna lose the game
and by the way we just have another move
- after Queen c2 there was a rookie a
Czech king came to h7 by fabbi Queen
came back to C - yeah if you were
thinking about capturing this bond or
maybe even capturing this pawn watch how
a 45 check is on tap yeah because I
can't see what else you could be
dreaming of and then he plays Queen e5
and then it's sort of like well he
hasn't played it yet I had it on board
just oh you had it on your because I
can't see what else you would okay well
exactly the alternative being resigns
but Queen c2 and I saw Queen e5 on your
board and I thought you know like why
would you play move like Queen 35 and
your rook who are somewhere that c7 rook
yeah
could I put it on a t-34 okay just give
me a just put it on a three and okay and
I'll I'll play Queen e5 and ask you to
beat me okay well with pleasure and you
put the rook on a three and then how
does that help
I just want it on a super passes I'm not
even asking you for c1 exactly c1 I just
want to have an active easy I'm trying
to highlight the fact that this rook it
sure is like wandering once it can't
even go to a7 and make anything happen
because the bishop is defense so where
are you gonna put it I just want to put
it so my guess F so actually f7 is not
so far away so completely 5/5 and you
make some kind of random right a 5 maybe
it's Randa but I look at fate they just
shut you down if you were even thinking
lap yourself for thinking that you might
even get an active just one you got so
much material you're not gonna give me
at least one active yes it was Maurice
he said you know what I'm feeling I'm
feeling that this rug needs to go got to
go somewhere and I'm assuming that after
a five here's a fantastic idea night
only we're gonna fade and now we left
your g6 he has a threat I know I know I
know it's a it's just so bad so II five
check night II 6 well no rook f8 isn't
also required all right yeah well buy it
well again we rarely by the way this is
rare that we saw this for us
commentators that we ever see positions
like this I can't kill ya I can't recall
the time right I can't recall the time
we've got we've called a lot of dead
drops
yeah we keep on playing very used to the
drugs were used to I I don't think I've
ever in the history of my commentary
seen this kind of disparity of material
in the classical game and there's no and
and the player continued to play and
it's like a time pressure is right guys
plenty of clock time in 25 minutes right
I don't think I have you don't think
Nevers forget about forget about even
even commentary I don't think I've seen
this in my my history as a player with
playing against alongside all the GM's
and I must have seen it but you're
making a good point I wanted to go the
other way and say you know our friend
Peter Svidler if anybody has been guilty
of premature so I mean we you know we're
premature resignation nod yeah okay
sorry do we have on the board
okay very good d6 looks kind of tempting
because six yeah there's a fruitcakes
and again you know the night is don't
don't reach for the night and think
you're going to fork my king and queen
you're not that's would be an illegal
move in fact so Wow okay again you're
right
Maurice I can't recall offhand but I'm
sure it's happened that just someone
knows something
egregious where you're just so far down
in material just so far guys this is a
rare sighting very rare especially at
this level this is a rare sighting is a
rare sighting in any tournament level
let's say master play and above but this
is a rare this is something twenty eight
hundreds you can put you can almost put
this in in a book it just doesn't happen
strong players give up they realize this
is
hopeless you could keep playing and a
lot of youngsters on they might say I've
seen it happen in my mind I got a draw
[Music]
but not at this level at this level they
know this is a squashing a beatdown
we can sit we consider it respectful
that you don't continue to play in a
dead loss completely ridiculous position
so is this disrespectful would we go
that far as to say this is somewhat
disrespectful that when you get to this
stage of your career where you're in
tournament of your life your tournament
of your life and you know you're coming
in with big dreams I'm not going to you
know to say what is the right thing for
you to do I mean you you're the one who
has to live with yourself and well I
mean obviously he's saying I still think
I've got one shot I'm looking for one
trick let me ask you this question
please what do you think Erica's bar are
things right now Gary would have said
thrown in the towel long ago and what is
he thinking right now that the game is
continuing you do you feel like that you
know the gods don't do this marring the
game in some way I know it's I don't
wanna make tip your hat respect your
opponent you know he did a good job come
back come back next time that's right
continuing to play does feel a little
bit insulting yeah you know this point
yes because I think I think for us if I
had a student or you know usually you
would you would say let's say my student
is down a couple of Queens against a
good plug master right right right and
they come and say you know what the
right thing to do is the stop that's
Duchess now that's what's happened over
time now maybe it's not exactly the
right thing to do but it's what we
consider right the proper etiquette
well it's interesting that we're having
this discussion because a couple of
years ago there was another type of
discussion which was a discussion that
encourages grandmasters to play til the
very bitter end like I made on the board
you weren't allowed to resign you just
those arguments right there's like no
man when you're lost just let the guy
give it up I mean you know I saw I think
there was some event where you actually
have to play to play they would tell me
it was for check they said it was for
the facts okay exactly that what are we
talking about and the grandmasters were
like completely completely annoyed
because they were down at rook and they
have to play checkmate and what they did
was they just bring the King out and to
say this is my I mean I just want to get
checkmated an honorable yes what's
interesting here I know that argument
and there are some pieces there's some
part of the argument that I do
sympathize with if you have fans who
don't know anything about chess it's
satisfying to see checkmate after all
that is the end of the game that's the
conclusion we get that this sort though
this kind of reminds me of a basketball
game where it is one minute left right
one team is down 30 points right and
they're still going at it with their
first team no they did not blame can't
stop the game so right it's 30 points
there's a minute left right and what
normally happens in that case you bring
in all the reserves and then you stop
you just bounce the ball but what's
happening in the stands people are
leaving the fan
savvy enough to know this was done we
out yeah you wanted to play the mate but
their phase are going nothing
this was over I got other things to do
so there's a two sides to that story
right not always at the fans necessarily
want to see mate they're savvy enough to
know this is a beat-down we understand
throwing in the towel and when the guy
we understand when the referee says I'm
pulling these boxers up parts right all
right don't we're not waiting until the
guy is bleeding profusely and has the
brain injury you know we're stopping
this one so this one is at that level
right now
and it's also taking a lot of time to do
ding the Ren is stomping looking
thinking about move now again the
miracle of the odds you roll the dice a
hundred thousand times there's that one
time that somehow he messes up it's
possible it's possible
probably even then people say yeah
that's messed up the way you won that
game actually I was walking out and it
did happen that he tripped and fell and
smashed in you that's kind of messed up
right that's what we have now I mean
this is clearly over well again let's
remind everybody that tomorrow we have a
free day but for round 4 what's the para
means we're back in action and it's
going to be an exciting weekend para una
Karen are coming from a loss will be
playing is yummy probably actually one
of the leaders yeah a lot of how it was
one of the leaders in Sol will be white
against the lowest rated player it's a
fun opportunity for him to at least put
some pressure on the young Russian
vaccine Bashar legrasse will be playing
with white again one of the leaders I
guess in the district talk about a
veteran matchup that each other
yeah and England versus I'm use dearie
two of the more solid players but
remember that dinner and did the onigiri
in the Grantchester in the classical
formal last year with the black pieces
so of reignited England again was white
this is gonna be his third white out of
four games right somebody has to start
like that and he's gonna be facing
against the Dutchman looks like nice
rivalry so nice rival round four and
that MBL Grichuk matched most especially
that be versus young Kenny bounce back
okay he bounced back that's always a
topsy-turvy one will take a very short
break while we wait for this game to
finish don't go anywhere we'll be right
back
[Music]
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health
and strengthen it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities it sounds
like life and it's what you hear when
you really listen be surprised be
intrigued be delighted the world chess
Hall of Fame in st. Louis is nothing
you'd expect and everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
[Music]
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015
SLU partner with the same Louis chess
club to start a top-tier collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
team's inception slough obtained second
best university at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back we finally have the
result we're expecting a stinger and has
defeated Fabiano Khurana and let's see
the standings after round three its MVL
yonder Pavarotti and walked out tied for
the lead with two points and only half a
point behind it's Fabio Karan and
Alexandra Christian with 50% one and a
half points each Annie's Gary krill Alex
and cleansing learned by no means out of
it only one point behind the leaders but
they are tied for last with one point a
much closer tournament than what we were
expecting and a very very relieved
angler in he faced a lot of prep today
but he came back he held it together it
was a remarkable remarkable a victory
biting absolutely Maurice tell me your
thoughts amazing stalwart defensive play
by Dean Loren
he got out preps that was obvious some
of the most magnificent preparation
we've seen in such a long time
absolutely incredible the way Fabi
started the game he had to somehow stay
in it and he managed to keep his head
keep his equanimity and maintain his
composure and when his opponent started
playing frankly some waffle moves a
little h6 move here I move that looked
good on Queen b6 Queen III he said yeah
you could keep on doing those things but
you still got a proof compensation and
he was not able to and that allowed ding
Lorraine to come back take over the game
and win like a boss I gotta give him his
kudos absolutely was a fantastic
performance on his part and there missed
opportunities elsewhere so what you're
gonna do this is the candidates after
all mistakes are gonna get made we have
a I think the score is pretty reflective
off the play so far I don't think you'd
expect a lot more separation you might
expect Telecinco to might have lost
another game but the fact that you know
he's where he is at minus one that seems
normal enough for a strong player of his
caliber so I think the tournament as
numbers that make sense
maybe not the players we expected we
might have expected father
to be a plus-one I didn't learn to be a
plus-one these this way of getting to
this score this standings I should say
that has been quite surprising Thank You
Murray's fair results but what a result
today I mean this was an amazing game I
really eat it he was needed for the
tournament for dinner in absolutely I
mean I can't see him coming back even a
draw was tough right but - I lost was
just the yeah the eggs you're done yeah
yeah but it was a great result
tournament wide open just rustic
tomorrow guys don't turn in but the day
after join us here because we have
fantastic games for you it's been a
pleasure commentating with you guys
today but as always Olly hundred Maurice
thank you everybody for joining us we
will see you not tomorrow the day after
tomorrow on Saturday thank you goodbye
[Music]
[Music]